there's no time
hey ladies and gentlemen here we are
once again we are here yeah well you
know where else would we be
saturday moving off the damn camera i
know it's like okay there we go
there he goes he just scoots right off
the edge
hopefully i can hear you turn it like a
little bit more toward you because
you're farther away
from the microphone and sometimes when
you do that you kind of turn it toward
me and then i'm really loud and you're
really good yeah
now see here's the thing we need to get
a boom because this camera's [ __ ]
covering my gorgeousness
camera's ever in your gorgeous is
covering my gorgeousness oh no
there we go oh no i'm very excited
that'll work i'm very sorry that it's
covering up covering my gorgeousness all
of that
awesomosity all that [ __ ] beef here
we go
all that goddamn beef all right so uh
you guys know what's up today shroud of
touring
yeah yeah and some other religious
relics too because i thought that would
be fun to like
pepper that through yeah kind of getting
sick of true crime
i kind of like the paranormal stuff it's
a little more light-hearted
we can get more [ __ ] up and have more
fun and
tonight we don't get [ __ ] up with we
gonna get [ __ ] up with christ
we're gonna talk about the shroud
and there's some weird [ __ ] with the
shroud you know what i mean um
some people blow the shout off just as a
[ __ ]
religious forgery
well i'm gonna say if it's a forgery
it's a good foragery we'll get into that
we'll get into that you know what i mean
[ __ ]
it came from another time when when
belief
and faith was very important you know
what i mean that
the church wanted you to believe and
maybe believing in something was
kind of a better path in life because
they were kind of dark times if you were
[ __ ]
from a poor family and didn't have very
good prospects
your prospects lied mostly in the
afterlife
so maybe believing in something like
this would help you get through it
you know yeah can you imagine like
living back then every day must have
just been a horrible
yeah trial of depressingness
yeah the church was the media yeah it
was news and movies and music
and everything and radio all wrapped
into one you went down there to listen
to
listen to [ __ ] music and look at
pretty pictures and
communion with [ __ ] god and then you
got back to [ __ ] till in the soil
yeah and like you said it's kind of like
you know people are like ooh look at the
nice stuff after i'll have these angels
and like a harp
and i'll get to fly around like a little
chair a bit if you were to
if you were too intellectual and kind of
too worldly
you'd realize oh man all this shit's
fake this
[ __ ] you know they're just
using me up
promise making promises they'll never
keep you know and then you'd get
depressed and kill yourself
it's better to believe back then it was
yeah yeah
hell yeah i mean you know i can see that
yeah well even rich people believed you
know the church was a was brought into
power through rich families all going
all the way back you know third century
rome
they were the ones that brought it in
you know it was uh it was kind of the pc
of its day
yeah yeah well you know don't [ __ ]
rape women
you know what i mean like you have to be
told yeah you know don't [ __ ] kill
children
you know uh don't do that stop stealing
[ __ ]
okay i mean
everyone everyone has equal value in the
eyes of god you know what i mean
those are all things that didn't exist
in the wrong
in the roman world the roman world was a
hierarchy
you know with [ __ ] elite roman men at
the top and then
everybody underneath them and they were
all getting the shaft
getting pooped on they were all getting
the shaft figuratively and
literally yeah because you know what i
mean you could do you could screw
anybody you wanted to screw
as long as you were the [ __ ] they were
below you in rank you could do whatever
you wanted
yeah and um you know
murder was on the table they did that
yeah
but that was that was cool just depended
on the situation and who it was
if there was a big rank difference you
know if somebody underneath you [ __ ]
pissed you off you killed them but well
they shouldn't have pissed you off you
were above them in rank
yeah that's just how it went
christianity was kind of a
i guess you could say relatively
humanist in certain ways
so it kind of for the time at the time i
mean it's i don't know if i
would go that far like but some of some
things about it were
everything happened in phases yes stages
and uh you know after the fall of rome
most of the [ __ ]
fighting men became basically [ __ ]
bands of mercenaries later on involved
evolved into kind of like the knights
you know and they did whatever they
wanted you know evidently they were
[ __ ]
pretty ruthless it was like you know you
didn't even have they were doing [ __ ]
that you didn't even see like in the
[ __ ] wild west
yeah they just see a woman they go hey
let's rape that woman
yeah yeah let's drink that she's just a
woman
yeah you know well you know she doesn't
have any weapons
it's not like her parents can do
anything to you they're just serfs
they did that [ __ ] down the street
asking for it well it belongs to you
that's no they look they didn't look at
it like it just said that it just
belongs to them yeah it was just
it was their right yeah you know well
like i said i i do feel like
people kind of particularly wealthy
people back then saw other people as
just
objects for their own use i think they
still do
well that's true yeah i think they still
do but in a lot of ways it's better than
it was at least maybe now some of them
feel bad about it or they
yeah there is at least at least
there is at least the appearance of
recourse to a legal system
at least they make it appear that way
and for for most people is
i guess it is a reality but
i mean all you gotta do is just look at
the child island man you know what i
mean there must be a lot more of that
going on we don't know about
probably yeah a couple people have been
asking what's wrong with our volume
turn the [ __ ] up let me see hold on i'm
not really sure
it looks like it's all the way up let me
check this out
uh mic volume
let me turn it up some
okay let me see if that
all right uh
is that any better i turned it up a
little bit
how's the sound turn turned it up in
here but still not perfect
let me let me do to do what the hell am
i doing okay
i'm i don't know what i'm doing i'm like
not even that drunk yet
turn it up to 11. i don't know if i want
to do that or not
turn that [ __ ] up to the left i'll turn
it up i'll turn it up
it was only on three how's that i turned
it up well that's like it's just getting
better
okay getting better all right let me
turn i'll turn it up even more
all right i don't even want i don't want
to be like yelling at everyone's face
because then like if we laugh
these go to 11.
i'll put it up i'll put it up to nine i
put it up to nine how's
that is that better oh thank you nico
thank you
there we go so everybody says that's
better somebody said yell
yeah win a rebel yeah
all right that was good that's really
weird because i never had to go in there
and adjust it before and i haven't done
anything with it maybe it [ __ ] up
yeah who knows i don't know periodically
[ __ ] changes
just because that's your poltergeist
just doing much better yeah
yeah okay so that's good yeah i turned
it up like nine
dbs yeah decibels or whatever energy
i guess so so all right so before we get
into
talking about all the religious relics
and whatnot
we have a whole bunch of like shout outs
and all kind of fun stuff that we
uh have to talk about
so um if you are a patron remember you
have until
tomorrow at noon eastern standard time
to vote on next week's
movie retrospective and next week's uh
episode
topic so go in there and vote looks like
a lot of people voted on the topic and a
few people voted on the movie
uh at the moment like two movies are
tied so we'll see like which one comes
out on top i'll wait until tomorrow to
figure out
what it is but you know if you're a
patron go in there and vote
um also wanted to do we did this on one
of the matinee shows but
we always like doing the main show like
i said so we're gonna give a
thank you to louie for sending us
the movies heat yeah i haven't seen that
one
oh it's good everybody says it's good
yeah it's good and uh
the frank langella dracula directed by
john badham which came out 1979.
oh it's really good i like that one as
well i like that one as well
also thank you very much ken again for
sending us the
veggie slicer so that i can make some
waffle fries i'll use it
we need to make some waffle fries yeah i
can make it
also uh remember a long time ago because
i you know i periodically
designed uh board games card games that
kind of stuff and it's like i have a
bunch of them uploaded but
you know you have to order them and get
a proof copy like before you can put
them up for sale so
some of them are kind of you know a
little bit expensive so i've only been
like
ordering one like every so often however
i did
order my edgar allen poe trivia game
red death and there it is yeah i think
it's beautiful
yeah so it's like look that's the back
of the box
yeah oops well it's upside down it's a
board game
yeah it's a board game and it's uh i
don't know i don't know which way i'm
just kind of
cards and stuff it's basically you're
just trying to
i mean the whole point of the game is
you're trying to show them the board
you're trying to get out of the uh
prince prospero's mansion
yeah and uh the way you do that open
that box man i can't get that [ __ ] over
um by answering questions about edgar
allan poe
so wait a minute here's the board so
we'll see there's a picture of it on the
back of the box so you can kind of see
it on there but
holy crap okay yeah it's real high
quality this board is very very large so
yeah yeah so yeah i made that there
can you see it i can't see it yeah it
comes with two decks of cards and a
bunch of little play
playing pieces and there's a little
bitty telltale heart piece in there
which is my
favorite and instructions look it's a
little heart
yeah can you see it
there's a little heart like it looks
like a real heart
volume at nine podcasted 13 1313
thank you very much thank you very much
dljm
15 pounds thank you very much
uh hey okay
okay yeah that's the conference link
above oh i guess i guess we're talking
about the strange realities conference
that was another
um that was another um thing that i
wanted to mention
because i did a radio show last night
with tim benall
from banal of america like the radio
show
he does on coast to coast and uh yeah i
think he's worked with coast to coast
and uh we talked about true crime it was
super fun i was on for like two hours
and he is actually also speaking at the
strange realities conference and in fact
we were talking last night he's like oh
i have the time slot right before yours
so uh you know so he's going to be on
friday night like right before me and
then i'll be on at 10 40.
uh that's september 25th so
you got to get tickets for that and it's
a three-day thing and there's like a
whole bunch of people giving talks
i also did like uh i'm not sure if
they've posted anywhere because that was
live also
but i also did kind of like a um like a
teaser like a round table
it was me and uh kiki dombrowski and uh
stephanie quick and we did like kind of
a live thing with conspiranormal where
we just talked about
what we were going to talk about at the
conference it was about an hour long
i'll have to put the
i'll have to find the link for that i
was looking for it earlier and i
couldn't find it so
i don't know if they have it like
archived someplace they're they're
asking me what i'm drinking
i'm drinking silver tequila and rockstar
yeah the one in the black can
rock star regular
all right dave altman says yes it's up
okay that's good
and then i'll put the put the link on my
website because i already put the
already put the one for the tim binol
show on there
also oh also thank you logan for sending
me a paypal
donation earlier today so thank you very
much for that
also ken the same person who sent me the
the veggie slicer thing
he sent me a very weird article today
about and maybe some of y'all in the uk
have heard about this
but apparently there was this guy and he
has just been arrested or and or
convicted
in devon england for
repeatedly raping a 15 year old girl
after he had convinced her
that he was a ghost imagine that or like
an evil spirit of some kind
damn what a gimmick
yeah i was like well that's certainly
i'm hurrying i'm a ghost
yeah put your pants down that was
apparent well that's kind of like
apparently from what i could gather
because like the that's horrible
like the the like the the article wasn't
really that long so it's like i was like
dude i'm trying to imagine it i need
details about this like more than they
supplied
but um apparently like the girl was like
really
like scared of like evil spirits and
ouija boards and stuff so she was real
like superstitious
yeah and i guess he had been doing stuff
like
making her think her house was haunted
or making her think her room was on or
something like that's kind of what i
gathered like from the article
and then he convinced her that he was
like an evil spirit and that she had to
have sex with him or
or he was going to like [ __ ] her [ __ ] up
i don't really know what
yeah so it's like i mean they caught him
because he had molested a couple of
other
like younger girls too like 11 12 year
old girls
by and all it said in the article was by
putting coins in his pants
and making them play hide and seek with
him damn
and i was like and the picture of this
[ __ ]
jackal was just like the phantom of the
opera
no he just looked like he was a young
guy joe was a young guy
he just looked like i mean he looked
like a
a yokel like some kind of like toothless
[ __ ] like over
you know what i mean it looked like one
of the summers look like florida
it looked like florida man something
from the embrace not that bad but i mean
he didn't look like you know
he looked like you know like like
somebody that
raped someone by con by convincing them
that's it you know picture that guy
that's what he's not here
i'm actually a ghost yeah bend over yeah
damn can you imagine like i read that
article and i'm just like
what kind of [ __ ] is that what how does
a [ __ ] make that work
especially when he doesn't have any game
i don't know
it's ridiculous i don't think anybody
could convince me
i'm looking at by looking at the
comments there's somebody in england
drinking that
pomegranate rock star with [ __ ] gin
that might be pretty good all right i
might actually
yeah i might actually do because i'm not
a big fan of like energy drinks like i
said but
that actually sounds kind of good yeah
i've never had i don't think i've ever
had
gin with anything other than tonic you
know what i mean
i'm sure you could mix it with other
things but it's like i always whenever i
have gin i always have it with tonic
chin's actually pretty good with seven
up
okay i can see that seven i don't think
i've ever had it with seven seven after
sprite
yeah well no i take that back because i
think one time
yeah one time a long time ago when me
and a friend were going to a concert and
we had
some gin and we stopped and got a big
gun yeah and i think it was spriter
seven up that we got in the big gulp and
then we put gin in it and yeah that was
pretty good
yeah well it's like it's like gin and
tonic with a squirt
with with a twist of [ __ ] lime or
lemon in it
that's you know that's that's true it's
just a sweeter version of that
now you're making me want gin and tonic
i used to drink gin and tonic a lot in
boston when i got out of the army for
some reason i was just drinking those
goddamn old man drinks i was drinking
old man drinks
before i was an old man i should have
known better
i had i i was under the influence of
army guys that drank old man drinks
you know what i mean if it was sweet
they go man you dweck now you know they
they didn't mix anything with any kind
of it had to taste kind of bad
or you weren't a man yeah because it's
like
you know i got caught up in that heaven
forbid like you enjoy anything in your
life
well you develop a taste for it you
develop a taste for it
you know like everything has to be
shitty or it's like it's a ding on my
masculinity
well no there are some there is some
[ __ ] there that [ __ ] you know you
develop a taste for
that you can't mix anything like like a
single malt scotch whiskey
yeah you don't want to mix that with
anything okay
yeah because that's the good [ __ ] the
rocks that's it maybe you put some
[ __ ]
some ice in it that's it because that's
good [ __ ] you're paying for that
flavor you know what i mean uh
but but yeah there was a lot of stuff to
wear
if it if it tasted too good it was for
it was for women
yeah that was the mentality like you
might as well have a little [ __ ]
parasol sticking up out of there
yeah do you guys remember uh if any of
you used to watch kids in the hall back
in the day where they had that whole
it might have been a recurring segment
the girl drink drunk
like the guy that was like he would sit
in a bar and get drunk off his friday
[ __ ]
drinks with all the like [ __ ]
parasols and [ __ ] sticking out it was
really funny
thank you xanada xander says can't stay
the whole street i know xanada
he's a good dude can't stay the whole
stream but appreciate you guys i will
catch the rest later tonight have a
great week okay dude have a good one
go get loaded with jesus that's what
we're doing yeah go get loaded with
jesus
yeah alex says with those old guys
basically communicating that enjoyment
is effeminate
yeah yeah i guess so exactly like i said
everything's got to be hard yeah
it didn't seem that way at the time
though yeah all right but these are the
same dudes that we're trying to [ __ ]
snort snuff yeah yeah
we were in the world nobody you're in
the army
so you're trying to [ __ ] outdo each
other i guess
i tried to snort some that snuff just
made you [ __ ] sneeze like [ __ ]
crazy yeah see i don't get the point of
that it's like
it's like snorting cinnamon up your nose
or something like that why would you
want to do that
in powdered [ __ ] tobacco no i know i
know what it is i'm just saying it's
like
like what's the point of it well
according to my understanding of it is
that
the guys who use the low the guys got
addicted to it who were working in the
tobacco
industry and they were loading and
unloading trucks full of bales and
tobacco
the bottom of the [ __ ] truck would be
filled with that [ __ ] dust
and that dust would blow out they'd
smell it they got addicted to the smell
of that dust
because it was nicotine so then he
started to sell that dust
yeah nicotine dust and that was old man
[ __ ]
that that was old man [ __ ] in my dad's
day that was
that was old man [ __ ] my grandmother
yeah that was old for them
yeah i don't even think they sell that
anymore
no i remember i haven't seen it but i
remember snuff boxes as a kid
i remember seeing them in like grammy
houses or and like yeah and i knew what
they were because i looked it up
one time or my grandma told me or
something like that some of them were
like really pretty
yeah they had little spoons yeah yeah
yeah i've seen them like i
see them in thrift shops and stuff i was
[ __ ] nuts man it was another time
dljm78 cinnamon is nice though i put it
in coffee yeah so do i
actually i either put cinnamon in there
or a one drop of peppermint oil you
can't put any more than one drop of
peppermint oil otherwise you won't be
able to drink it
because it's like you bring it up it's
just like wow
these nests said he got [ __ ] up in the
army trying to outdo a dude repellent
i [ __ ] loved rappelling man [ __ ]
you know i was aerosol qualified
we were in egypt and one day and it was
on a
it was it was like on a day where there
was really nothing going on
we had a rappel tower there at south
camp in egypt
they set up the repel tower and i was
doing that [ __ ]
aussie repel aussie repel and swiss seat
repel man did this [ __ ] all day i got
good at aussie i'd get myself a whole
bunch of [ __ ] slack
and just jump off the [ __ ] tower fall
about i don't know
10 15 20 feet and then start then pull
then [ __ ] put my [ __ ] arm out
[ __ ] break the brake hand
remember the brake hand yeah that [ __ ]
was sucking
and can't breathe not hit i like your
sound you don't hit on the feet
i got pictures of it man i was like
i felt like [ __ ] batman i was batman
all [ __ ] day
jumping off that tower everybody else
got sick of it i kept getting in the
line over and over and over again
yeah this is fun yeah i haven't done it
in a long time
it's easy though once you once once you
get over it once you know what to do
it's easy i don't like i don't like
heights so i don't like it it doesn't
look
difficult you know what i mean we were
talking about it like the other day
because we were watching that korean
zombie movie hashtag alive and somebody
did it in that uh or you know kind of
repelled down a building
yeah and you said something about it and
i was like i could probably do that if i
had to but it's like
i don't know i don't like heights so i'd
probably be like i'm not looking
we'd repel the swiss seat out of the
[ __ ] helicopter i think it was 200
foot
chopper repels and then we'd do um
out of the ch 47 out of the chinook
helicopter we do fast rope
there's a big old silk rope about three
or four inches in diameter it was almost
like a flexible fireman's pole
and we'd [ __ ] all run at it in a big
line and go down it all at once like
it'd be two of them sometimes there are
two of them i think i think it was two
one on either side
of the [ __ ] the helicopter i remember
correctly
and um the whole helicopter be on the
ground just in like
two not even a minute just a few seconds
yeah
yeah like 50 dudes it was [ __ ]
incredible man it was a lot of fun
fast rope yeah it was funny man we
one time we were fast roping and a guy a
couple of guys on top of me
somehow lost control of the [ __ ] rope
and he didn't have his
he didn't have a hold of it with his
hands it slipped and he was hold doing
his arms like this
and he missed and all of his weight
was on top of all of us and we were all
sliding down with our hands man it was
it was it was like five times as hard
because we were supporting the weight of
a man yeah the whole stack of us
yeah it was like an incredible a whole
stack of yeah knows what i'm talking
about he probably went through that
school
yeah yeah said i tried to get to the
ground in two pushes and swung in too
fast and my feet would then went
vertical
yeah yeah i wanted to
i saw this uh a comment up here richard
hines says i've been watching since
100 subs and audio only remember those
days yeah yeah
i would have guaranteed that you would
have had at least a hundred thousand
subs by now that'd be nice wouldn't it
nobody loves us you guys love us yeah
we're probably shadow band
we well you know i i always feel like we
have quality not quantity
yeah you know what i'm saying the show
has only been going on for about two
years i think
uh uh no actually maybe we started it in
summer of 2016. oh so has that been that
long yeah so i think it's actually been
four years
although for a long time um we didn't i
was it's weird because i was actually
watching
one of our older like when we first
started going to video
yeah and i happened to see one because
somebody commented on it and i was
looking at it
and i was like wow the video we had back
then looked really shitty yeah yeah like
it was so like washed out and gross
yeah but we had shittier equipment even
our equipment isn't all that great right
now but it was a lot
yeah well it's a lot better than what we
used to have and i was like wow now
now we look like a [ __ ] hollywood
movie like compared to that [ __ ] back
then yeah
well you know what was funny is that we
when we started we really didn't take it
that seriously
no we really didn't and it's it's just
really funny how it started it's like
now we have something going up every day
and it's just like i was scrolling
through like before we went live i was
scrolling through all the videos i'm
like holy crap look all these
videos we've made and we didn't make
money for a long long time
yeah we weren't really doing it for
money no we were just doing it to
[ __ ]
help promote books yeah and just because
we like to talk
you know it helped promote books it sold
books
but um excuse me when the show monetized
and then
super chats it kind of went cha-ching
you know it kind of like oh i guess you
can kind of make some money doing this
yeah you know it doesn't pay the bills
but it helps
yeah i mean you know on top of like all
the you know other top everything else
other stuff that i have going on because
i have several three or four different
incomes
you gotta have yeah you gotta have more
than one income stream on the internet
game it's got to be a bunch of stuff
happening at once you can't depend on
anything any of it it's all
up and down yeah well that's why like i
said it's good to like diversify they
kind of tell you that and everything
then if one goes down you can kind of
push more in the other direction and
[ __ ] like that so you know
yeah just fyi um so do you
got do you want to start talking about
the show i start the show i lost my
stream on my little tablet oh no
gotta get out of it what happened oh
yeah it busted
you get back in there get back i don't
know it has something
it has something to do with this tablet
loses its connection to
the louis said were you guys in a
different room when you started on video
um it wasn't a different room but
different lighting
it was different lighting and also this
the desk that we're on right now used to
be over in that corner yeah
um like behind me different angle so we
move yeah so it's not so it's the same
room it's just a different angle we just
like
moved the [ __ ] to the other side of the
room and like kind of switched
everything
so it was the same but john said she
found us when she wanted to know about
summer win she loved
that that haunting yeah yeah they didn't
watch that when we watched that episode
like 20 times
that's actually the best episode of the
haunting even though
summer win the case is very much blown
out of proportion
in that episode that episode really they
did a good job
writing that episode and making you
think that there's more to that case
than there really was
yeah if you actually look at summerwind
you'll see why people didn't want to
work on it
i mean it was just a hulk yeah it looked
like it was falling apart that's what i
mean
yeah yeah ken said did you receive and
get to try at your waffle fry maker yeah
i just i guess you weren't here
yeah like like i just showed it um we're
gonna we're gonna use it like later on
this week because i wanted to show it on
the show like before we put it in the
kitchen to use it
so yes thank you very much again i'm
glad you uh dropped by
uh yeah what oh alex says whatever
happened to these psychedelic green
screen backgrounds
yeah we just did that a couple of times
yeah and computing power
yeah has tom cooked pookie what we're
talking about
we would never yeah she was in here
earlier like tearing up an envelope
i gave her one envelope to play with but
she still wants the
the pile cause she's like well this
one's already messed up i need all these
new pretty ones
but uh i don't know so she got mad
because we blocked off all the other
envelopes and she was like well the hell
with you then and she took off
so i don't know she'll probably be back
in a little bit
but yeah yeah it looks like i got it
working again all right it's going no i
didn't cook pookie we talked about
cookies running around
we would never cook scary even to think
of that i don't i know i don't even like
to think about it that reminds me of
like what happened
what happened in that movie one bedroom
i didn't see that he did somebody
cook the cat yeah i don't want to hear
about that [ __ ] that's what i mean
that's why i didn't watch that movie for
a long time because that [ __ ] was in the
trailer and i was just like oh yeah
that's good i'm not in amazing i don't
like even hearing about anything
happening to [ __ ] little domestic
animals and
and children i don't know yeah i don't
like it yeah it's like i can watch
horror movies where stuff like that
happens but it really bothers me and
especially
it's i know this is terrible to say but
like stuff happening to cats and dogs in
movies is way more upsetting than stuff
happening to children
and adults [ __ ] them i don't care you
can do whatever you want to them in
movies
but yeah i was like leave the kitties
and puppies alone goddamn it
i know people are trying to be like
shocking and scary and everything cause
it's a horror maybe but seriously
just you [ __ ] up [ __ ] to people sandra
said she found us because uh
the the because of uh the original night
stalker and we were funny it was before
they caught him and then they caught him
just a couple months later and i said i
told you i was right that he was a cop
the only thing that we were wrong about
was we thought that he was probably dead
yeah because he had stopped yeah i
thought he was dead i think that was the
only thing we got wrong
i mean i'm not you know i'm not sure
because i haven't listened to that
episode in a long time
actually i was just talking about it on
that radio show last night we were
talking about golden state killer and
how he got caught and
how we did the show because after he got
caught we did another show about him
like to say
but i think we did think that he was
dead because we thought well he stopped
so he must have died
but obviously we were wrong about that
uh but yeah
so you gonna uh
you want to talk about the shroud of
turin yeah i'm ready all right
so i mean most people probably know what
the shroud of turn is i don't want to go
like
too much into like a big history lesson
or anything like that i just kind of
have a
an overview that's just like a couple
paragraphs or whatever
so basically supposedly uh shroud of
turin
uh length of linen it's actually um a
herringbone what they call a three in
one herringbone weave
which was kind of fancy and it was
supposed to be
the the linen that covered
obviously the dead body of jesus after
the crucifixion
right now the way it was that they kind
of laid it out
and then he they laid him on it and then
like folded it over
you know what i mean like burrito style
or taco style or something like that
so it's kind of like this uh it's about
14 feet 3 inches long or 4.3 meters
for everyone else in the world um and 3
feet 7 inches
wide or 1.1 meters for everyone else in
the world
now the thing about it is that so you
get your your front of your thing
the front of the shroud and the back of
the shroud and it supposedly shows it's
a very faint image i mean most people
have seen it i've got a picture of it
right here
i think this one is like a full length
yeah there we go that's like the front
of it
got a little man covering up his little
junk there
which uh i guess well i guess that's
kind of how they buried them back in the
day they're like well
we have to put we have to put the hands
over there over the little sizzler there
because
that's just
i'll just say it that was that was like
how they
i don't know that was like you know the
thing where they put the the
hands like crossed over like that but i
guess it was kind of like tradition to
just
which seems weird to me like why would
you cross people's hands over their
crotch i don't really know why because
they were observing their body
yeah i think they put them in clothes
but yeah it's like what
that seems like the easy solution it's
like well you just put some pants on the
dude
i mean seriously a lot of problems
there's a lot of problems with the image
on there at the beginning that's yeah a
lot of problems with that image
yeah um i'd have to say first off
that is not a first century
[ __ ] middle eastern male what's being
pictured
okay the hair is wrong there's a lot of
stuff that's wrong about that
that's definitely uh a very anglican
[ __ ] concept of what jesus looked
like
well and we'll get into this in a bit
but it's like
the man depicted on this shroud quote
unquote um
looks like a medieval depiction of jesus
that's right
not like what actual jesus that's what i
just that's what i said i just use
different vocabulary
yeah and the thing about it is that okay
so
as i said it's it's a very very faint
image really
i mean here's another image of it and
this is like obviously a negative that's
blown up so it kind of looks like
but look that looks like an old man i
mean seriously to me it looks like an
old man
which jesus wasn't supposed to be how
old are you supposed to be 30 30 33
right
i can get off into this [ __ ] you know
with my [ __ ] knowledge of
mythicism you can go back and see the
episode where we had dr robert price on
and he's a super well known jesus
mythicist
a lot of people don't know what
mythicism is mythicism is not
atheism per se mythicism
is uh the idea that
the things that are in the bible are
mythical and that
jesus is a mythical character and
uh the more you know about the old
testament excuse me the old testament
the new testament
third century [ __ ] roman religions
even first century roman religions the
more you know about this subject
the more you know about the original
scriptures
in greek
the more you the more you kind of
realize that you're you're talking
you're not talking about a historical
man that had lived
all right you're you're talking about
you're talking about a a roman mythical
deity
that's what you're talking about but
that's for another subject
um there's just too much wrong with the
narrative
there's too much wrong yeah there's too
many there's too many problems in the
scripture
there's too many problems in history
there's too many problems with the damn
roman culture
all right roman culture did roman
culture did not worship
living people in the same way well they
did
but not in the same way christians did
all right uh
they worship they could worship an
emperor
but the emperor was was claiming to be
the descendant
somehow of a roman deity or of a roman
deity
and in some ways that's what's happening
with this with the character of jesus
but not so much in the way that that an
emperor would do it more in the way that
hercules would have done it yeah okay
son of god the whole son of god motif
is very roman very greek well it's very
old i mean it predates christianity by
yeah centuries at least yeah or more
right i was raised as a christian i came
up in a christian military academy
a lot of times when you hear people
talking the way i talk about
christianity they tend to hate
christianity
all right which i don't hate
christianity i like christianity
i don't necessarily believe christianity
is historical you know or that i don't
believe that the tales ever really
happened
but i'm not gonna say that they're bad i
think that they were misused
over the years you know what i mean but
they all
they all had their place in history and
overall i think it's a good religion
as long as but with the caveat as long
as you don't take it too seriously
that's really what it boils down to you
can believe what you want
all right just don't take that [ __ ] so
seriously that you start [ __ ] killing
people over it
or imposing things on other people or
trying to make your version of reality
everyone else's version of reality
the world doesn't really work like that
and really just have
tried to do that for [ __ ] aeons and
it never really works out
alex asked if there was a book we could
wreck one of robert price's books which
would be a good
introduction yeah well actually you can
get a lot of that free on the internet
just go
um what you okay if you want to know
about
old testament and really the new
testament
in many ways is a reboot of the old
testament
because the average birth narrative and
i say the average birth narrative of
jesus because there's about three or
four different ones
okay well and jesus isn't the only one
that has that almost exactly
either the the original archetype is
moses they have the same birth story
yeah
all right so you so jesus is already the
a reboot of moses
now ancient scholars
ancient christians noticed this but they
called that
like syncretism they says well that's
proof
because they have the same birth
narrative that's proof that jesus was
real
because evil dead too is the same story
as evil dead ones
therefore
and a lot of this has that means it
really happened yeah
and this is not this kind of thinking
isn't really
isn't confined to ancient people modern
people do it too
uh it's just that politics has excuse me
religion has kind of evolved into
politics
that takes the new that's it is taking
the place of religion and they're doing
that kind of thing today too
uh it's like confirmation biases and
stuff like that you know
uh so the the christians and the muslims
and and
and the jews they were not unique in
their ability to [ __ ] believe in
crazy things they did they
they believe in crazy [ __ ]
not necessarily that it's always harmful
though sometimes you can even nietzsche
will tell you sometimes believing a lie
is very beneficial
and that's what i was saying at the
beginning of this story sometimes
believing in these things is what you
have to do to get through life
that's that's really what this was about
which i don't you know i don't
um you know believe in any of this stuff
but if other people do it doesn't really
bother me all that much like i said
you know as long as people aren't
imposing their beliefs on other people
um i don't really care what people
believe to be honest with you
oh you know what i was gonna say is that
i was going to answer his question
uh just look up in on youtube robert
price old testament studies
and there's like a 12-part video series
the audio recording isn't that good
but he'll basically read to you most of
the important books of genesis this
genesis stories that's what it is
he's very interesting like he just comes
to craig he's very
professorial you know what i mean yeah
and when he reads genesis to you he
explains where all this stuff's coming
from you know that it's even coming
from the epic of gilgamesh yeah and
he'll even read from the epic
gilgamesh and show you that well the
flood story is borrowed from the epic of
gilgamesh
just that gilgamesh is actually written
a lot better
i read it in i read it in high school or
maybe college maybe first year college i
think i read it but the old testament
is basically the it's the septuagint
it came from the greek septuagint and um
that was the that was the original form
that it came in and it was kind of like
a
kind of like a hillbilly religion
compared to a lot of other stuff that
was
it hadn't been around long and only
people out in the middle of nowhere
believed in it
and it was kind of like a hillbilly
version of the greek pantheon
most of the stuff in in genesis
kind of has greek roots to it because
the greeks kind of had a diaspora that
went down into the middle east all the
way into persia
you know in ancient times there was no
real difference between greece and
persia they were they all worshiped the
same gods you know persia was named
after perseus
so the ancient jews who are not the jews
you know today these are the old jews
and they were they were not monotheistic
they worshipped a bunch of different
gods they had their own pantheon and a
bunch of different versions of
judaism some of them involving asherah
poles
and uh asherah was a [ __ ] female
serpent
uh who was god's wife kind of like
the middle eastern version of hera who
was you know
zeus's wife and that's why you have in
this in the in the old testament about
the serpent being forced to crawl on its
belly after [ __ ]
you know the whole fruit and the garden
the fruit of knowledge in the garden
that was punishing asherah to me because
women am i because women
but that's not how originally the story
probably went there's probably a lot
more to the story originally but it was
edited out for simplicity well like i
said
i mean up until for centuries
for centuries judaism was trying to
become a
monotheistic religion and the powers
that be
rebooted all those tales into being a
monotheistic religion and one of the
things you got to do is you got to get
rid of hera
you got to get rid of asherah the there
can only be one god
yeah there can't be two all right well a
lot of problems because you got god and
then his
sons all right and one of his sons
chose israel all right you know you're
talking about yahweh chosen is choosing
israel
well how many gods do you have now well
you have
you have you know um the father of the
gods
all of his sons you know him as angels
and then
the children that they bear with mortal
men
the bible was calling him the nephilim
but in you know
the septuagint called him the nephilim
but you know in the greek versions you
know they were just called demigods
guys like perseus and [ __ ] all right
it's that same [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it was happening in the egyptian
religions too well it seems like
monotheism seems like a very
it's not a real human con because it
seems like most of the um
religions that came about like before
that were all
uh you know had pantheons of gods which
in a way if you think about it coming
from an objective point of view and like
the way that humans think
that seems a lot more um in line with
the way humans think like you would
because humans have
intention you know intentionality in the
sense that whenever something happens
you think someone is responsible for
that
um so it makes more sense to me that
people would think
oh well the you know the tree has a god
and this has like lightning has a god
and this that the other thing
so just having one god that's in charge
of everything seems
yeah that i mean that's why it took so
long for that to come about because
that's kind of like a strange
and the jews were not monotheistic even
in the roman days
the jews didn't become monotheistic
until probably around the time
christians did all right you're talking
about maybe the third fourth century
because the romans clearly state that
they were worshiping many gods
and that uh you know josephus wrote
wrote all about it in the antiquities of
the jews he
josephus was jewish he became a roman
citizen
and wrote that book later on and he
wrote the history of the jews also known
as the antiquities of the jews
and he talks about you know that the
different factions of
of the jews uh in judea were
fighting over the trying to get rid of
these damn astral poles
and asherah was a [ __ ] serpent
goddess she's usually standing there
with a couple serpents in her arms
and it makes sense when you look at it
from [ __ ] sympathetic magic
you got something that's a serpent it
comes out of the hole and that comes out
of an
egg it's male and female it's like a
hermaphrodite
yeah all right it's a penis that comes
out of an egg that was in a womb
a hole in the ground all right and it's
kind of they they imagined it to be
something that it wasn't
the oshawa poles that symbolized or may
have been they know it was a
pole but it might have been a phallus
okay and the rest of the jews didn't
didn't like these they weren't they're
trying to get rid of them what's all
these dicks
all over the landscape well there might
have been some kind of crossover with
asherah and baal you know which also
just means lord they're not really sure
which lord they're talking about there
were many lords many balls
because that was the title exactly just
meant title as a title
and that some of the balls they were
sacrificing children to
and some of them evidently they weren't
in the the history
the record is incomplete but there was
just a bunch of stuff that
even romans didn't like they didn't like
it going on over there either human
sacrifice
and some of this stuff seems to be
phoenician because
the phoenicians were doing that kind of
stuff too
you know they were sacrificing children
and some of that stuff even goes up
into ireland and it could have been that
a lot of this
prejudice stuff might have had something
to do with baal
yeah you know so we're middle eastern
religions going going as far as ireland
you know it was a different time back
then sorry i was laughing because victor
garcia just said there was simon the god
of hairdos
and also jeff the god of biscuits i i
get that reference that's uh eddie
izzard
but yeah so yeah i'm just taking it off
another pack another thing about the
serpents too
is that i feel like and please correct
me if i'm wrong but wasn't that also a
symbol of rebirth because it shed its
skin
yeah it's real and it was almost kind of
like resurrected
phallic but it came out of an egg yeah
which that
that would disturb an ancient person and
then the egg was in a hole in the ground
and then then this so many holes yeah
and then
this same old this same phallic
dick-shaped snake lays an egg
so egg comes out of a dick is it male or
is it female it's an oral
that's what they that's what they were
thinking they were thinking that it was
which makes sense when you put it that
way i mean did it
goddess that can create things yeah and
uh and can kind of create itself in a
way like i said
right and well they had to get rid of
that and that's really what the serpent
in the garden
of eden was all about it didn't have
anything to do with satan
nothing to do with that no that was a
that was a later much later
uh you know story in the old testament
satan
is a servant of god yeah he's just
another one of god's angels
and he does god's bidding and even in
islam
it says that satan cannot disobey god
he's an angel
well he's kind of like the dude that
like tests people he's the prosecutor
yeah he's god's main prosecutor and even
in
jeopardy i'm sure you're not like
slipping up in the book of job he
appears in heaven and god says where the
[ __ ] you've been he goes dude i've been
on the earth and was walking all around
on it
says what'd you see he says i saw your
servant job
dude was [ __ ] dude is [ __ ]
stunting
and i tell you what he's only stunting
because you're good to him
yeah give him to me let me test him i'll
show you he don't give a [ __ ]
guys like all right how much does that
go right i'll tell you what you could do
it just just don't kill him
okay i won't [ __ ] his [ __ ] up he [ __ ]
his whole family up
and afterwards he wouldn't praise me
because he goes he goes guess what
god job dude's the [ __ ] he's with you
he's down okay i'm gonna give him i'm
gonna double his [ __ ] earnings
and give him double of what he likes my
favorite part was how he said how he
gave him another wife and kids yeah like
here you go here's replacements well
they're possessions yeah
they're like goats or camels that
clearly disstated
that's my favorite part women were
possessions yeah and you know it's like
here you go they're all interchangeable
right
well they still are in many cultures
they still are possessions in many
cultures
i guess but yeah that always like
cracked me up when i eat when i was a
kid that was just kind of like
here's the thing though here's a this is
what a muslim would tell you
okay because i know i know the thinkings
and i know islamic teachings
they would say who are you to judge
god's morality
god can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
see that's that's where it
shades into like [ __ ] being dangerous to
me like i said if you want to be
whatever religion you want to be and
it's like you just you know you live by
that and you keep that [ __ ] to yourself
then that's fine
yeah but the minute you start thinking
well god's on my side
and god can do whatever he wants
therefore i can do whatever i want then
we have a problem
a red hero with a thousand faces i did
too but a long time ago
there's another one you should read it's
called um the power uh was it
the power of myth yeah that is also
again yeah power of myth that's
good yeah those are all very good all
myth is true
they teach teaches truths and bible
mythology is true
innocence or at least it was true yeah
yeah
not literally but it's like you know
it's
teaching a lesson about teaching a
lesson yeah but a lot of it
some of it though especially when you
get into the new testament
a lot of the teachings especially when
you start getting into things like
the pauli materials most of it is sit
down shut the [ __ ] up listen to your
bishop
that's a lot of it that's what a lot
meanwhile the bishops are writing that
in there put that yeah
yeah yeah make everybody just shut up
and listen to me okay
now many people think i'm going off on
christianity we're not on a trial but
i'm gonna [ __ ] back this up because
we may have christians in here
i always believed
that christianity was an offspring of
the teachings
that came from the four gospels and i
was wrong
[ __ ] christianity predates the four
gospels
the paulie material is older
the gospels were written afterwards all
right
um the church did not spread
because of the four gospels the church
spread because of organization
church organization and it competed
against other
organized religions probably mostly
mostly
mithraism which was a roman competitor
at the time
there was a lot of crossover between the
two mithraism is actually quite similar
yeah really look into the history
mithraism is like christianity mixed
with scientology
and yeah you're buying you're paid to be
a [ __ ] wizard
you can buy you you're being a wizard it
had a it had a supper
i wish i could pay to be a wizard
they're skeptical sculptures
their sculptures from mithra mithrik
temples
show uh a a a supper
and uh so the christian
last supper story probably came from
mithraism
uh there was also not only was it like
scientology it was also it had a lot of
astrology in it
it had to do with your birth sign and
they were trying to do they were doing
horoscopes
what was that series that we watched a
long time ago
where i can't even remember it was so
long ago that we watched it but they
but where he basically broke down like
all of these
bible stories in like an astrological
fashion and how it all made sense
yeah we kind of talked i think we talked
about it a little bit on one of the
jesus mythicism shows a bunch of
different hidden stuff
in there because a lot of the [ __ ]
they're referring to is the astrological
yeah a lot of the stuff that was in one
of one of the gospels
one of the gospels yeah yeah it goes
through all 12 signs
that's what i was thinking of yeah and
and it shows you the man carrying the
water that's something this the fish and
it's going through all the yeah aquarius
pisces it does it all
in order too well today that would be
seen
as a hint of something being fraudulent
but in those days
a person who knew his astrology
was would have seen that as well of
course this story
must be true everything's happening in
the order of the [ __ ] zodiac
signs science that's just it's a science
[ __ ]
because so that was science of the time
i shouldn't make fun they didn't so this
[ __ ] is scientifically proven
that this is true so they had different
ways of doing things back then the
different ways to look at it
well yeah astrology was absolutely a
science but yeah but i think i mean it
was a stepping stone to astronomy and
actual science but
you know to them they didn't really see
it yeah yeah it doesn't matter
look you understand the science that we
use today eventually would be disproven
would be replaced by a better version of
science
and that just happens over and over
again you know what i mean we'll say oh
you know what these newtonian physics
that's actually all [ __ ] it just
looks like that really it's this new
quantum nowadays i don't know if it so
much replaces it it's just builds up
builds upon
like some some things i mean the ship
that's established now i would be very
surprised if somebody came out and
said this entire thing is wrong but i
can see how little details and [ __ ] like
that might be proven wrong in the future
but i don't think it's kind of like
i don't think it's an astrology
astronomy situation where astrology was
just
like is obviously like completely wrong
back in those days you would have been
if you would have been a real educated
person you would have been reading that
bible story
on its own because there was no compiled
new testament
all those books were separate and you
just joined this church and they [ __ ]
gave you this book and they said read
this this is about the guy who founded
the church his name was jesus
okay so you're reading it and you're
noticing that oh [ __ ] all this shit's
happening
in the [ __ ] order of the zodiac so
lines up so this shit's scientific man
it's scientifically [ __ ] proven
yeah it'd be like you're reading he goes
oh you know what that makes sense in
[ __ ] newtonian physics
that did happen that's what that would
be like well it's like they only had
about five books back then so it's kind
of like if you read those five books you
were like the smartest person on the
planet well i think a lot of it also had
to do with the fact that the entire
culture was filled with things like this
yeah and so so
third century christianity would not
have seemed out of place
yeah to you it would be like oh okay
this is normal [ __ ]
normal mainstream [ __ ] everybody
believes stuff like this yeah their
story's a little bit different but i
like this one
yeah that's what it was that's it was
mainstream entertainment
yeah there wasn't much difference
between a church and a club
because the cult of bacchus they went
there and [ __ ] drank sang saw a show
got loaded and that was true it's fun to
me that was the only fun they had back
then some of this stuff they
some between all the black death and all
the plagues and all that some of those
i'm talking about roman church some of
those ancient roman churches they were
having orgies in them
today if you were to go you'd go man
this is the [ __ ] s m club
it'd be like that yeah you know
alex says flat earthers would make a
good topic for the show i think it is
actually thank you victor
um he gave me five dollars for getting
the edius reference
i love eddie izzard seriously yes i'm in
the god of paradise
the thing is a lot of flat earthers is
is a joke
it is but it would probably be funny i
should say though that um
tim benall who is going to be uh giving
a presentation at strange realities
conference like
in the time slot before mine i think
he's going to be talking about flat
earthers yeah because it's really easy
to prove that the [ __ ] earth is round
anybody can do that
i feel like you're a bad [ __ ] if
you can prove that it's flat
and i've seen a dude try to prove that
it's flat he's in the airplane
and he's he's going look we've been
flying forward
for an hour and we haven't gained any
altitude we should be going off
and he's got a [ __ ] he's next to him
in the seat he's got a level
yeah you know what i mean with the
little bubbles in it i've seen it yeah
see we haven't dipped at all
we're not following this dude
knows that the [ __ ] earth's around
he's [ __ ] with you yeah he's trolling
i kind of feel like pretty much i mean
in this day and age
unless people are like really really
backwards and uneducated i feel like
most people that are
that have like the savvy to make a
youtube video know god damn well that
the earth is not flat
i feel like they're just being
contrarian or they're just trolling
people yeah glenn glenn's going on about
astrology is symbolic it's not not back
in those days
not back and forth well back in those
days it was considered yeah
back in roman days they thought that
[ __ ] was scientific they had all
different kind of theories to prove
how these stars affected you they didn't
though it was just a way of [ __ ]
making money off people they believed it
to be true though
that it wasn't it was a pseudoscience
yeah they wasted so much [ __ ] time
and effort on that [ __ ] but
they made actually mechanical computers
and [ __ ] to help you compute
birth dates and star alignments they
really really believed in that [ __ ]
all right so you want to get back to
talking about the shroud now yeah yeah
all right talk about trout jen so
so like i said uh as most people know so
uh we'll talk about like i said the
inherent problems of the image on the
shroud
later and i kind of want to get into
because i'm really interested in art
forgeries and that kind of stuff
so we'll kind of get into maybe some
ways that uh the
the shroud could have been made uh in a
bit
but so another thing that is kind of a
ding against the shroud of turin
if you are so inclined as to like think
it was actually the
thing that it purported to be which i do
not think it is
um was that you really didn't hear
anything about the shroud
until about the 1350s you know what i
mean
then it just kind of came out of nowhere
um
and it appeared in this uh in the
possession of this night called jeffroy
de charney
uh this was in 13 and in 1389 they put
it on exhibition
now even in 1389 for christ's sake
when they put on exhibition the bishop
who was local to the area said
that it was a fake he said that it was
uh
and this is a quote cunningly painted
the truth being
attested by the artist who painted it so
some people have speculated that maybe
he actually knew the dude that made it
because like i said no there was no real
provenance of this
uh prior to this except for like a
couple little things that may have been
referring to that or may have been
referring to
a couple of other things which i might
get into a little bit uh later because
this is not the only
like religious relic by a long stretch
this is just like the most famous one
and this isn't even really the only
not necessarily burial shroud but you
got like you know veil of veronica you
have like all this other like
[ __ ] like surrounding the death and the
resurrection and everything that people
have tried to like make money out of
so even back then some people were
saying it was a fake
so however at the at the time
you had uh the anti-pope from avignon
uh clement the seventh now
he wouldn't say like whether he thought
that
the shroud was accurate like was uh real
or not
but he basically said well if people i
mean i'm paraphrasing obviously but he's
like well if people believe that it's
real
and it makes them like act better then
[ __ ] it
yeah let me get to some because like
people most people back then were
illiterate so it's like they needed like
visual representations
like to believe and if they so that's
why so many churches
that's why there was such a brisk trade
during the middle ages in this kind of
stuff
because people needed like a visual aid
to come in and they'd be like oh
you know it is true and then they'd you
know cough up the money and they'd act
right there's something called pious
forgery
yeah which i guess modern people
probably really don't have a good grasp
on
maybe they do the church forge stuff and
people
related with the with the church forged
stuff there's a lot of forgery
in bibles there are some whole books
that are forged that are in some
versions of the new testament
i don't really remember which one the
name of it it was uh
it's not in most of your common bibles
but
some have said that [ __ ] half of half
of the books
may be pious forgeries um
back in the day people would forge stuff
not because they didn't believe in
christianity but but because they did
they would say look i know that this is
true
and i'm a [ __ ] true believer but i
need more ammunition to bring the faith
to the unfaithful
yeah that's exactly what that's how they
were like justifying so they would
justify
faking something to save souls yeah it
didn't mean that they were
bamboozling people because into a false
religion
they believed it they just needed more
you know well like you said it was um
and even some popes at the time
like some bishops and [ __ ] like that at
the time acknowledged this and were
basically like look since
so many people like you know can't read
or they can't
you know they listen to a sermon and
they don't even know what we're really
talking about
but if you have one image or one
something that they can come and look at
like a shroud or like you know a crown
of thorns or something like that
that that makes a lot more impact on
them
than a sermon would and then they're
sprung up this whole economy
of fake relics yep and um
guys would make some kind of [ __ ]
impressive
looking relic uh sometimes out of human
body parts
like the hands out if they'd find from a
cemetery and they would say it was like
like the hand of [ __ ] john the
baptist well they got his head somewhere
although that got stolen a while back so
they just have a fake one there now
they'd make a nice thing and they'd show
up to some
you know local bishop and say uh you're
my lord uh i have a damn the head of
john the baptist and
[ __ ] they're like oh yeah oh you do
let me see it nice and there they're
going oh
yeah here's the head yeah oh yeah i got
you yeah yeah
how much you want for that and that's
exactly how much it went down because
the church would buy it
yeah yeah well that's the thing it's
like you know you [ __ ] have doubting
thomas's finger
that he's stuck in the wound on the
jesus side you got a bunch of those
you got like [ __ ] heads you got
[ __ ] yeah you had uh
the head of john the baptist there's a
couple of those floating around
um you know there's all kind of like you
know toe bones finger bones
right uh the holy pre-piece yeah jesus
jesus foreskin jesus is foreskin there's
a bunch of those floating around
um which i kind of want to get into a
little bit because that's my favorite
well they're proven that they're trying
to prove that jesus was [ __ ]
circumcised
well the the thing about it i think that
i think why there was such a
proliferation
of holy foreskins um i believe there
were at least 13 in circulation that
they know of at various points
throughout history
is because jesus was supposed to be like
according to the story he was supposed
to be like ascended into heaven right
so the only parts of his body that were
left on the earth
were his foreskin because that was
removed obviously as
you know per jewish custom so that was
like the only thing that was left
so they you know they couldn't have any
bodily relics like they have for some of
the saints
you know like their mummified bodies or
their hands or whatever so they didn't
have any of that for jesus because he
was supposed to be gone like his body
was supposed to be gone
so uh yeah that was pretty much it yeah
because if you had jesus body you could
say wait a minute he didn't ascend
yeah exactly well and there's some [ __ ]
about the shroud too that if
even if the shroud was accurate which i
do not think like by any church of the
imagination
um it's even problematic within the
confines of the story that they're
trying to tell about it
you know what i'm saying the fact that
there is quote unquote blood
on it that would suggest that jesus was
still alive
when he was put in the tomb because
otherwise the blood would have dried you
would think
and that's like that's like against
because he was supposed to have died on
the cross right
yeah but not in the mind of a medieval
person they're like what clothes yeah
dead body can bleed yeah close enough
yeah they didn't know
it must have been covered with blood
well you need the blood stains in those
areas to show
jesus because yeah because that's the
thing like the whole
the thing on the shroud even though i
have to say hold on
maybe maybe okay is the volume better
did you turn it yeah because i turned it
way up on the
on this program it might have been
turned down low here
maybe somebody must have just done that
maybe we just did that when we were
moving it because i don't usually mess
with that
did the volume get better i turned it up
on on the on the microphone
yeah nobody's saying nobody's saying
well everybody's saying it was okay
before but then somebody else came on
and said it was really low
i don't know what like how that happened
somebody must have like [ __ ] with the
volume down but i don't know
who knows i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on zach just showed up and said
hey guys how much did i miss oh my god
an hour and 15 minutes you missed all
the fun stuff not really there's a bunch
more fun stuff to come probably
but yeah so and the thing too about the
shroud and like i said you really have
to
because if you see the [ __ ] like i've
never seen it in person
obviously but i've seen photos of what
it looks like i've seen videos of it
where they were working on it
i mean the image on it is very very
vague
so it's like you really have to like
take a picture of it like do a negative
to even see anything on there um you
know with all these quote unquote wounds
and [ __ ]
the thing that always bothered me well
one of the many things that's always
bothered me about it
was that whoever made it when they put
the quote-unquote blood on there they
made the blood
so it was almost kind of like dripping
down like the outside
of the hair kind of thing you know what
i'm saying
which wouldn't happen if you had like
just
kind of put it over a body and it's like
you know what i'm saying it just doesn't
look like what it would really look like
if you put that over a body
they're saying it's low turn it up like
turn it up more
okay well i don't know how
how much farther it's going to let me
turn it up
is that better we'll see how's that well
it's like talking a normal tone of voice
yeah tom still hasn't worn his nipple
belt yet
okay i don't i don't have a nipple
though but it seems to be i'll be all
all turned up doesn't it
yeah i mean i turned it up and that's
all the way up yeah yeah it's weird
because we never really had this problem
before i always kept it like right in
the middle because that seemed to be
all right yeah sandra said it was better
sounds good
okay that's it remember the setting all
right
yeah i had to put it on like 12. i had
to like increase it by 12 like in here
and then we turned this all the way up
i've been having computer problems in
general
it's all it's all [ __ ]
discombobulated everything's
discombobulated
like poltergeist it's poltergeist [ __ ]
i'm just saying
all right yeah so um so basically it
kind of like went from church to church
like i said
even back then there was a lot of people
that said you know they thought it was a
fake but that's okay because you know
people had to come look at it and it
would
make them more pious or whatever um
however like after
pretty much in the from the 1400s on it
seemed like most of the popes just kind
of were like yeah it's totally real
like it's because they've been around
forever yeah i would seem like they they
kind of took it for granted even though
when it first appeared it was like nah
that's just like a painting whatever but
they were like but it's fine
are you going to get into the [ __ ]
what kind of cloth it's made out of and
all that yeah yeah because i like i said
i'm
i'm into art forgeries and i've always
been fascinated with how it was made
yeah there's a lot of stuff about it
later on i mean they should have known
at the time they didn't know at the time
they knew the chip was fake
they knew it was fake it's just good for
it it's a good fake because it is kind
of weird i think how they did it but
the thing that uh hard to say that
always like weirds me out about this
it's almost kind of like
because look they did you know spoiler
alert but they did
uh carbon 14 dating on the [ __ ] three
different universities
separately did carbon 14 dating on it
middle ages yeah uh 1260 was the
earliest date
probably somewhere around the 1350s
which was about the same time that it
first appeared yeah it's not all
in the record i mean it's old but it's
not not old enough
it's not jesus old yeah this 1200 years
difference yeah
12 1300 years difference uh so that's
like a big difference
now the thing that um that always gets
me about cloth
piece of cloth in the european
environment doesn't let doesn't last
that long
it wouldn't last john well the thing
about you have to be
[ __ ] super protected the thing about
it is that even after you would think
that after it was carbon dated and
whenever they carbon dated i think it
was in the 90s sometime like 98
yeah you think that put it to rest you
would think that would put it to rest
but some people are so
invested in it being real
that they will come up with the craziest
[ __ ]
yeah to try to chip away
like i've seen them say stuff like well
um
you know that it's not definitively
paint on there no there was really blood
on there even though they didn't really
find any they didn't find any blood on
the shroud they found
like a few molecules of blood like on a
piece of tape
that supposedly had pulled some fibers
off the shroud which honestly could have
come from anywhere
um you know and people will say [ __ ]
like oh well it's not really paint
it was like one of the craziest things
that i heard was that
um the image was put there by gamma rays
when jesus was ascended into heaven like
it burned it into the
i was like really i'm like looking at
the person i'm like you really really
believe
that that happened okay no jesus only
ascends
um in one of the
of the gospel stories it's in john
because they're not all the same they're
not all the same
okay and um well in the other ones they
say he vanished we don't know where he
is another one the first
one they don't mention but in in
in the main ascension story not only
does he ascend
but a huge cross comes out of the
[ __ ]
um tomb and says some [ __ ] and then
wait the cross talks the cross talks the
cross says some stuff as he is our lord
and our lord and all kind of
said and makes an announcement proclaims
some [ __ ]
and then jesus goes to heaven and the
other ones he appears to them
uh [ __ ] remember his followers and
say see look i'm
i'm in the flesh still you can touch my
hands and feed
they're not all the four gospels are the
same they're
not if you they kind of read the same
a little bit if you read them all
separately but if you put them side by
side and read them chapter by chapter
and note for note
the story gets longer as as as
they're adding details they're spicing
it up right and the very first
gospel which i think is what pretty much
everybody says
is is the oldest and i think it's mark
all right
is it matthew i think mark um
i'm thinking yeah i think it was mark
that i was thinking i can't quite
remember i
i would have said mark yeah mark is the
oldest one i believe
and in that one he just dies doesn't say
anything about ascension
and that's probably the original gospel
story it was kind of a downer
well basically i mean the story was they
opened the tomb and it was empty that's
and these later no that's later the uh
the first one he just dies on the cross
it doesn't say anything
about tombs i remember correctly i have
to go back and look but he no there's no
ascension
dissension was added and it was kind of
a [ __ ] apocalyptic view of like
the romans murdered him that's basically
those anchors the end that was like
that was like but that wasn't enough you
know what i mean they added three more
stories and it got more and more
embellished as it went and yeah they're
writing fans
yeah and um john
was the last one and that's the fanciest
one and usually
john is the one they're making the movie
about
well because that's not all the good
stuff yeah that's the most exciting one
yeah now there are some differences you
know but i think john was also the one
that had
uh uh the woman washing his [ __ ] hair
washing her hair with his feet and all
that kind of i think that's in that
and i think that's in the i think that's
in john but john's the high tech one
but what's funny is that from a literary
style john's the most roman one
yeah all right and that's just not first
century
no probably more like
early third century yeah you know so
later
like i said there a lot of these i kind
of feel like people think that
even nowadays because they're all like
codified into one book like people have
a sense that it was written at the same
time but there's not there's like
centuries in between some of that yeah
and a lot of it is like they're
commenting on
the older [ __ ] and they're commenting on
a lot of books that didn't make it
in there because there's a lot of like
apocrypha
that this whole idea
of
some kind of jewish street preacher out
in judea
okay he's from bethlehem making miracles
and [ __ ] everybody seeing them and
on that on the back of that a big
christian a big religion is formed
no that didn't happen because all those
stories were written
after christianity already existed
the oldest stuff is coming from the
[ __ ] pauline epistles and it doesn't
say anything about any of that
stuff in it okay and it doesn't mention
where jesus comes from
it only vaguely talks about the
crucifixion
most of it is most of it is about
uh sit down shut up and listen to your
[ __ ]
that's what most guys say yeah put that
in there put that
and it most of it is about this is our
supper and [ __ ] their supper
and our you know and our people and
their people and our believers
our ship's just better and this and yeah
and what they're talking about is that
there wasn't one christianity there was
a bunch of christianities
yes we're fighting well that yeah like
there is today
there's a bunch of christianities
southern baptist stuff
is not going to be what [ __ ]
presbyterians and [ __ ] catholics it's
different
well that's why and it was always that
way and if you really look at the
pauline material
they're not talking about a jesus that
was born they're talking about a jesus
that was
in heaven at the right hand of god he
was one of
[ __ ] el shaddai's sons next to ya
higher than yahweh higher than michael
all right and if you were to accept his
blood
all right you could bypass
you could bypass the old law and be
saved by grace
because in order to be saved by the law
mosaic law you just can't follow those
laws there they have to do with giving
up your first born children and all
kinds of weird [ __ ]
which you know i'd rather not actually
so you're either going to be saved by
following moses's law or saved by grace
and that can only be done by accepting
the blood sacrifice of the lord
all right grace much easier and what
they're talking about there is they're
talking about
scapegoat jewish blood magic yeah you
know what i mean you take
a lamb and you sacrifice that and then
you let that you put the sins of the
tribe on a [ __ ]
escape goat and drive that off into the
wilderness
yeah and that's what's happening all the
sins away and that's what's happening
in the [ __ ] crucifixion barabbas was
released he was the evil one
yeah okay and jesus the lamb was
sacrificed
if you accept that blood you're washed
clean this is
just old old testament jewish blood
magic it's just an updated version with
humans instead of animals
they're saying that it happened in the
past yeah
and and and these stories are saying
that this actually happened in the past
in roman history
but it didn't they're writing this story
200 years after it supposedly happened
yeah maybe 300 years yeah it didn't
happen
uh they know everything about pontius
pilate they know what he did and what
his character was like and he didn't
crucify any jesus yeah that was a real
dude yeah that was a real dude but
they're
they're you hammerizing jesus they're
putting him in the past
what's that they're yeah they're putting
him into the story yeah putting him into
the past
version of the story saying that he was
a historical person that lived
no no you're talking about what this
originally what that's why they're
saying
he was born of a woman he was
born of a woman [ __ ] everybody's born
of a woman
what are they talking about they're
saying why do you feel the need to point
that out
they're pointing that out because most
christianity of the time of the writing
jesus was never born he was just in
heaven
yeah he was like an ethereal an ethereal
being
and now in the pauline epistles there's
something about
he was uh i don't remember the exact
wording but it says that we
we in the actual greek it would
translate
like we see before us him being
portrayed
as hung up by the principalities
we see him before us being portrayed as
being hung up by the authorities
something like that well they're kind of
mistranslating that we see him
before us crucified
by the roman authorities what they're
talking about is they're talking about
in heaven jesus being somehow attacked
by
archons sky demons the
his other brothers that for real sounds
like a transformers villain
yeah yeah because there must have been
another story at one time where jesus
did something in heaven
and his brothers the other sons of god
killed him for it and if you accepted
his blood this metaphysical [ __ ]
blood
your sins would be washed away and you
could go to heaven
without having to conform to mosaic or
law so it's a way of getting around the
law
just like the scapegoat sacrifice yeah
that's how i came to terms with all this
christianity
nonsense connor of azlan asked hey tom
on what religion
were you raised christianity yeah well
what particular
denomination would have been well would
have been southern baptist
i my family were not religious so i
don't really
i mean i knew about it but we didn't i
never went to church as a child
you see having lived in brazil and being
in
in catholic style catholic based
societies their
big difference between protestant
societies and catholic societies a big
difference protestant
protestantism is a lot more germanic
it's a lot more about discipline
um it's kind of like [ __ ] comparing
capitalism and socialism they're they're
very different
uh the the the the
south american catholic stuff is very
permissive
all this shit's a sin but it's okay if
you do it that's really what it is
like you can do it as long as you
confess it long as you confess it's okay
that's not the way that's kind of [ __ ]
up yeah that's not what southern baptism
is southern baptist stuff is
more like islam it's more about
discipline
you do something wrong you must be
punished that's we're going to flog you
you have to be kept
you have to be kept to a certain
standard and it's a very much about
worth
work ethic if you don't work you starve
you know that's the [ __ ] ethic you
know it's like
and so they have their different
strengths and weaknesses let me see what
everybody's saying
i'm like out of drink man let me make it
over yeah should maybe another one let
me let me talk about
i think i said before when they did the
um the carbon 14 dating i think i
erroneously said 1998 it was actually
1988. yeah
make you a joke um but yeah one of the
first things like even back in the
[ __ ]
uh late 19th century they noticed that
the image on the shroud looked like a
photographic negative
which in some circles like if you were
inclined to believe in the reality of
the shroud
was what it said it was then they were
saying oh well how would anyone in the
middle ages how would any
how would they have known how to do that
kind of thing like they didn't know
about photography and all this other
[ __ ]
whereas i mean one that's
kind of erroneous because they did have
camera obscuras which we'll get into in
a little bit
um i'm not saying that i think that
that's how
it was made but i think that's one
possibility
but i do kind of feel like just the
scent
i don't know just the fact that it
looked like that
i think in a lot of ways like people
that already were inclined to believe in
it
thought that that made it seem even more
you know divine or whatever if you want
to use that word just because they had
the perception that
a forger wouldn't have known how to make
something that looked like that
and the thing that bothers me i you know
it's like i read a book
a couple books about this um
you know i watched a couple
documentaries about it to me
it seems like one of those things where
once they did the carbon 14 dating in
the 80s i feel like the question should
have been settled and it's like and i'm
not saying you know it's a cool
artifact it's cool to like talk about
like how it could have been done
um you know kind of the artistic thing
behind it
but i feel like that should have been
like okay well somebody in the middle
ages
made it by some way we're not entirely
sure but you know we have a lot of
options like as to how it was made
but it's definitely not from the first
century it's definitely not jesus you
know just everybody calm down
but the fact that people are still
talking about it making documentaries
about it
and making it seem like it's still a
mystery
is very strange to me because i feel
like every single piece of evidence they
come out like the second they came out
with the news that you know
three different labs did carbon 14
dating on this and they all got a date
between
you know 1260 and 1390.
um you know right in the middle of the
middle ages and right in right around
the time
when the shroud first appeared like in
the
in the record in the historical record
thank you very much
so you know which makes sense like
somebody made it then it turns up
somewhere
it's like nobody knows exactly what the
providence was that makes complete and
total sense you know
just with a lot of the other religious
relics because it was a huge market for
them back then
so i feel like the sense you know the
the fact that that happened in 1988 and
then people
immediately came out and started saying
oh well
you know they must have you know the
fact that the shroud got burned like
back in a fire in the 1500s you know
maybe they took a piece from the part
that was burned and
the carbon from the burning like made
like messed up the
you know messed up the dating like
messed up the thing i was like one in
three different labs
and also the people that tested it
we're very careful to like because it
has been patched up and it has been
burned it was in a couple of church
fires
like over the centuries and they
specifically and i saw the pieces that
they cut off of it
they didn't take any of the parts
because the patches are kind of all in
the middle bit
like the seams and the patches and
everything so they like really took care
not to take
any pieces from that like to take it
from the other part
so the fact that they're just kind of
coming up with anything that they can
try to come up with to make it seem like
it's
still accurate i've even seen people
come up with
there's this one like illustration i
can't remember i think it was like some
kind of book illustration the book came
out in
1190 i think it was and there was an
illustration in it
of something that kind of looked like
the shroud of turin and it looked like
it had like some of the same
like markings on it like there were
these like little dot markings that were
very specific
to like what the shroud of turin looked
like and they're like well look see that
means that it was around
like before you guys said it was like
before the carbon dating
i was like yeah but this book is still
from 1190 that is still more than a
thousand years
newer than it's supposed to be so it's
like it really seems like they're
grasping at straws at that point
yeah you know what i'm saying okay i
gotta address the comments
uh con we're gonna um we're gonna do one
on the mormons we talked about the
mormons all right yeah that's it's in
the box here yeah
[ __ ] um they're real interesting okay
there's a lot of gnostic [ __ ] in there
they were they were into a lot of that
forty and [ __ ] archaeology and
everything uh
yeah look it's really strong is it
strong yeah well that's good
i hooked you up they were the
the mormons i appreciate the mormons the
the mormons could write some [ __ ] man
uh [ __ ] joseph smith [ __ ] he was
at the top of his [ __ ] game he was
the
he was the l ron hubbard of his time um
yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
but he knew how to write that
you have to understand something people
oh here we go i'm gonna [ __ ] try to
put it to you
he's laying down something i'm gonna lay
some [ __ ] down
holy scripture okay
is a genre of literature
kind of like in the way that [ __ ]
comic books or a [ __ ] you know what i
mean marvel comic is a genre of
literature
well i see all of this [ __ ] is a genre
of literature and i'm not [ __ ] on
religion or on marvel comics it's like
it's just the same it's storytelling
that's what people do
and if you're gonna make a religion it
has to be made a certain way
and um jefferson smith [ __ ] knew what
he was doing
he knew exactly clearly because people
are still like believing in that [ __ ]
now that's right
and uh okay let me put it this way
is mormonism any more false than [ __ ]
conventional christianity
no no it's not it's about historically
the same
about the same so just because
you might be a catholic or a protestant
don't be looking down your nose at the
mormons because their [ __ ] is about like
yours
people just look down their nose at it
because it's newer because it's new
right a couple thousand years from now
that'll be just like any other of the
other ones if it's still yeah and it
will
you know it might be i don't know if
it'll be you know the origins of it we
lost in the midst of time because we
have a lot more like information in our
fingertips nowadays
right but it's i mean the the process of
starting a religion
is pretty much the same everywhere and
again that's all
what l ron hubbard did and what joseph
smith
smith did were [ __ ] great feats you
make a [ __ ] religion from nothing
in your lifetime yeah the difference is
is that elrond hubbard made something
that you can
actually get your hands around and you
can you can actually prove that it's
false
because it's making a bunch of claims
that you can prove to be false
scientifically joseph smith kind of did
it the old school way
it's so esoteric you can't get your
hands around it enough to disprove it
well see that's the secret
secret i always felt like if you want to
start a religion or a cult or whatever
you want to call it
um keep it vague enough yeah it's just
like if you want to be a psychic
right keep the [ __ ] vague enough that
nobody can call you out on [ __ ] when
you're wrong
but if you get something sorta right
then like people will remember that [ __ ]
better
because that's just like how people
operate ron hubbard tried to make
dianetics a science and as soon as you
start doing that
it means you can disprove it no bro
don't do that
right keep [ __ ] and well the thing about
christianity too
and the thing about like in the shroud
of turn in particular it seems really
weird that after they did the carbon 14
dating because here's the thing
what would have happened if the carbon
14 dating
had come out publicly and it had been
like yep this is first century
um even though that wouldn't have
necessarily proved that it was jesus's
barrel shroud that would just
have proved that the fabric was from the
first century which wouldn't really
prove anything
but if the carbon dating had come out
the way they wanted
they would have jumped right on this
science has proven the religion but the
fact that it didn't come out the way
they wanted
so they have to say oh well the science
must be wrong they must have taken
you know a burned piece or they must
have taken like a patch that was added
later or they must have had
so they have to come up with like all
these reasons why
the science had to be wrong because the
answer that came out wasn't the answer
that they wanted
and i mean like even later on they keep
coming out saying oh well there's all
these like
there's these little uh molecules of
like various plants and stuff on it that
could only have come from jerusalem
i'm like even if that were the case um
you know the molecules on it from these
particular plants are so small that they
could have come from
anyone that handled uh the shroud at any
point in any time
um but the fact that it just came from
jerusalem
doesn't prove anything yeah i mean it
just proves it was in that part of the
world
at some point that doesn't prove that it
was jesus's
that doesn't prove that he ascended to
heaven
or resurrected or anything that doesn't
prove anything
so to me it seems like they're just kind
of
as i said they're just like grasping at
straws because they so badly
want it to be real you could explain
that maybe somebody took it to jerusalem
at one time
that's what i'm saying somebody put
offerings around the [ __ ] from jerusalem
exactly that's what i mean there's a
million explanations for why that could
because it's not like it was saturated
with the [ __ ]
it's just they found a couple little
things it's like oh these plants and
they only grow in this part of the world
i'm like that just means that piece of
cloth was in that part of the world at
some time
in history which or somebody that was in
that part
of the world like touched it at some
point in history so that doesn't prove
anything or it might be total [ __ ]
it might have been something that was
just from [ __ ]
switzerland well i well in another way
too i feel like that whole argument is
probably spurious to begin
with because i feel like the dude that
made that claim
he just yeah i think he just like had
some tape and then he sent it to another
person it was like
hey look there's these little like
things on it from these flowers and they
only grow in this part we're always
trying to find
something with jesus you know his
ossuary or
if when you know these scriptures real
well and you understand what mythicists
are saying
there was no jesus not as you know it
you're just sorry yeah i don't really
think he was a real person
in the sense not in the sense that
people understand it yeah
for a while i thought well maybe there
was this street preacher
okay that taught some of this [ __ ]
cool [ __ ]
and then they kind of made a religion
around him nah there were street
preachers cool street preachers all over
there was tons of them there were
tons of those and what he's saying
what jesus is supposedly saying in those
scriptures this [ __ ] that was lifted out
of [ __ ] like
socrates and um a lot of it was stolen
from other
other roman well it was just a mishmash
i mean like i said it was
just if there was a if there was a
historical jesus
nothing more of him remains in those
scriptures they have been picked over
and over and over again
by churches and christians over
thousands of years
editing re-editing redacting you know
there's just nothing there
the everything every story we have about
jesus every quote that he's supposedly
saying
all came from something else none of
it's even original
it was things borrowed from other
religions yeah from other [ __ ] that was
around at the time
the new testament and the old testament
too the entire bible
and not just our bible the islamists
the koran the hadith the sunnah
all of them are [ __ ] perfect examples
of darwinian evolution of people [ __ ]
taking things out that got them in
trouble and replacing passages to get
them off the hook
and over time the system got tighter and
tighter and tighter
until it became foolproof that's what
they're doing
yeah and that's what scientology does
you know they constantly
reissue [ __ ] they [ __ ] re-edit some
stuff every now and then i think they
got it down to where they're going to
keep it now but
although every now and then they like
re-edit the books and then you have to
buy a new set you can buy a new set
because they haven't how much does the
set cost nowadays yeah
it's like several thousand a few
thousand dollars yeah i remember it was
like three thousand or something left
yeah
probably like his completed works and
it's like look we took out like this one
period where
ron hubbard didn't mean to put a period
there like even though he's perfect and
everything every now and then like the
typewriter slipped and he didn't mean to
like yeah
yeah but no they've they've picked over
every one of these religions they've
been
picked over and over and over they've
gone through them so many times
every time every time somebody read it
and picked up an
argument says hey wait a minute hold on
how could that be true here it says this
but we know back in this book it says
something else
that's a contradiction they'll go in
there and fix that damn contradiction
and then be like that [ __ ] never mind
it's right like some 1984 [ __ ] we've
always been
never happy yeah exactly so a thousand
years later that [ __ ] is tight as hell
2 000 years later it's [ __ ] foolproof
there's nothing in there that remains no
no problems remain in it
and you know that's why you can't trust
it
it just seems so exhausting it's
exhausting to me to have to keep up with
all this stuff
and like i said it just seems like so
let's talk about the shroud a little bit
and like i said why
why i think like okay first of all
i don't think just from you know a
a regular like normal common sense
standpoint this cloth does not look like
it was actually like
wrapped around a body you know what i'm
saying because
here you got the front of the body on
the front and then like
it's almost kind of like touching like
the back of the head and then it's back
like that
if this was actually wrapped around a
body
um it would be distorted you know what
i'm saying
there would be a space between here and
there the face
would be because like i saw like a
documentary about this a long time ago
that actually was really
was really good at like explaining this
but they're like look put some paint on
a
piece of sheet right and then like put
it on your face like that
and then put it out straight that does
not look like the shroud of turin
it looks like way fatter than your
actual face
because it goes around the sides and
then it goes into two dimensions
and the shroud does not look like that
it looks like
it looks like a person and another thing
too is that when
they've gone in there and like analyzed
the um
you know the proportions of the face and
the body and stuff
the head is a little bit too big for the
body and also the arms
are too long you know what i mean are
like longer than normal human arms
yeah the proportions also aren't right
that's what i mean the proportions are
off
the proportions are not right on the
image
for a cloth that has been hanging on a
3d
body that's what i'm saying it's not
there's no distortion yeah it would have
been highly distorted when you took it
off there's a lot of problems it's like
it was painted
or it was like a photograph of an image
taken head-on something like that
yeah now let's talk about because there
are a lot of different ways
that this could have been done even like
for the time period like i said look
we're
operating on the assumption just like uh
you know the carbon 14 dating said
that this was probably made in the
middle ages it was you know
a forgery um just like a lot of other
because like i said there was a huge
amount of like there was a huge market
for this kind of stuff back then
um this was probably a pretty uh a well
done one
i guess because even nowadays people are
still talking about them like
debating like how it was done but there
was a lot of different ways that it
could have been done
now you said that you tended to think
that maybe
it was a camera obscure done with the
camera obscura
yeah because what i remembered was is
that when they looked at those fibers
that's not paint on there it's some kind
of a chemical burn
that's what they thought from well now
the studies that i saw
said that they found traces of red ochre
and vermilion okay then maybe my shit's
out the window so it's paint
the study that i saw they thought that
it was actually some kind of a chemical
burn
which one thing you might be able to do
is treat that piece of cloth with some
kind of a chemical silver nitrate
and salt yeah i guess you and you could
do that
in the middle ages and then take a
statue of a dead man and put it in front
of it put the whole thing in a dark room
and draw
drill a little pin hole in the wall
camera camera obscura
right and then over time the light
shining on that
cloth through that with the body behind
it
might leave an image like a photograph
yeah and in those days that would have
been real [ __ ] spooky because
you could unravel it and you wouldn't
see any paint
you just see a ghostly image a ghostly
image
because i don't think i don't think
people of that time would be fooled by
paint on a cloth they've
they saw that before you know
yeah and the thing about it is that i
mean people talk about camera obscura
but i mean people it's a very simple
principle
of optics even though photography as we
know it wasn't invented so much later
they knew about it people did actually
know about camera obscura is i believe
back as far back as the fifth century
yeah
so basically all you have to do is you
have to make like a little dark room and
you have to just have like a pinhole
that light can come in and then you know
the light goes and it's upside down and
you can just
i mean it's a really long exposure time
obviously and you have to know about the
light light-sensitive chemicals
but it can totally be done with the
stuff that was done back then i saw
a documentary yesterday about the shroud
of turin
and even though these two chuckleheads
that were on here
we're trying to convince people that
leonardo da vinci had made it
even though leonardo da vinci wasn't
born until 1452 i think
and the shroud is known back in the
1300s so
the the shroud has provenance like
before leonardo da vinci was books i
don't so i don't think leonardo da vinci
made it
um and that's just seems like a silly
proposition but it also seems a silly
proposition that it's like yes leonardo
da vinci knew about
um you know camera obscura some people
even think like jan vermeer like used a
camera obscura and his work as well
so it's like something is funny though
davinci didn't mention any of these
[ __ ]
holy relics which let you know right
there that he knew what they were
he probably did actually knew what they
were and they knew they were fakes
yeah and like i said even a lot of the
popes and [ __ ] knew what they were fakes
but people knew about but the thing
about it is that i don't think there's a
lot of
um record of it of people knowing about
it
because back in those days if you talked
about that you can make an image on some
[ __ ]
like i can put a a thing out here and
then like
make an image over here like i think
that
you probably would have got burned at
the stake if you talked about that too
and how rich you were
true but that's kind of like true of all
times and places
but um so i think a lot of people kind
of kept it on the dl but for sure they
knew what a camera obscura was they knew
how it works like i said it's a very
simple
thing of optics they figured that out
pretty early um
so it's possible that so these two
people that were on this uh
documentaries i was saying that said
leonardo da vinci doing i don't buy that
because like i said he wasn't born until
like a long time after but
the one dude actually made he had like a
mannequin
made up to look just like g that had the
beard and he was like his
hands folded over his junk and
everything and he put it out in the yard
and then he made like essentially a
crude you know a camera obscura like
after he blocked off his window he had
like a little bit of a
you know hole with the lens or whatever
and then he left it
you know and he had the same kind of
linen and he hung it like in his house
and he left it for i believe it was 43
days
and um then he showed the linen on there
and it looked pretty good i mean it
looked pretty close
like it was very ghostly but
so is the shroud of turin yeah so i'm
not discounting the possibility that
someone could have used a camera obscura
to make that
because i could totally see that i could
see i
pictured it was it was like a camera
obscure obscura image of a [ __ ]
wood figure a wooden statue
yeah and then once they got the dance
because it would have to be real still
yeah and then once they got the image on
the cloth
they took some blood like pig's blood or
their own blood the girls cut their
finger and probably
just pig blood because you could just i
don't think that's real blood on there
because real blood when it's
gets old it turns black and the blood on
the
um you know i'm a true crime person i
know this so
you know the the blood that's on the
thing it's still red
like it's a dark red some kind of red
dye yeah and they painted that on one on
the wounds
marks of where jesus had his wounds
supposedly
okay and then they go look that came off
of jesus
see the blood on it and see where his
soul came up off of there
although there's a lot of problems with
it because that's not a middle eastern
[ __ ] death shroud
they did it a different way it was a
wrapping
it wasn't a single cloak piece of cloth
that went over them
it's more like a mummy wrapping my
understanding of what they used
well the thing i don't know like i feel
like in the in the bible
um it kind of says and some of the
paintings that i've seen that were from
like the middle ages or a bit later that
kind of showed it
showed it like i said almost like a taco
thing where there was it was just like a
long
kind of narrow piece of linen and they
laid the body on it and then they
doubled it over you know what i'm saying
so it wasn't like
wrapped up but the thing about it and
once again they're always changing the
story
that's what i'm saying and we'll get
into this a little bit too because i
also want to like mention the veil of
veronica which is another kind of um
you know venerated relic or whatever
because in the bible it does
specifically say
and this is um you know very much with
the custom of the time
that they not only had the burial shroud
type of thing but they also had like a
separate
like handkerchief or like you know a
small kind of sheet that went just over
the face
um so the and another thing too is like
the fact that it mentions that
would almost seem to negate the shroud
of turin because if it had another piece
of
cloth over his face then you wouldn't
necessarily be able to see his face on
the shroud
you know what i'm saying yeah so there's
just a lot of problems even with the
damn crucifixion
narrative out of the new testament
itself
they're doing this crucifixion on pat
during passover
that's a problem um i don't think the
jews would allow it on passover
uh also that's the time that they did
that dab
scapegoat [ __ ] sacrifice yeah so it's
just kind of leading
lending credence to the entire
crucifixion narrative is actually
nothing more than jewish
ritual blood magic i think it's a
mythical it's a mythical thing that's
a mythical story and i think originally
the original tale it was
is that it was happening in heaven then
they brought it down to earth and tried
to make it actually happened in history
and they put it back during the times of
[ __ ] pontius pilate
who was a roman occupier of judea who
who the who the jews hated all right uh
so it's just fishy the whole thing is
[ __ ] fishy
well as i said i like something that
don't don't be insulted people it's like
something the mormons would come up with
and when we get into them you'll see
what i'm talking about
it's something kind of like l ron
hubbard would come up with
you know what i mean yeah too many conv
too many too many different story
elements happening in a single story
it's just no
no too much was lining up with
ritual blood magic and [ __ ] that was
super traditional
it'd be like
some patriotic american dude
being sentenced to death on christmas
and the fourth of july simultaneously
okay with the [ __ ] oakland raiders
watching
and [ __ ] you're talking about it's
just too much [ __ ]
random happening at the same time you
know i mean
you know raiders
yeah it is happening in texas
during under the rule of [ __ ] ronald
reagan
you know man [ __ ] and george
washington was there
you know i feel like in 2000 years that
will probably be
a totally thing that will have happened
in 2000 years world war ii
will be about the united states fighting
dinosaurs that's
yeah i can see it yeah nazi dinosaurs
yeah oh i like that nazi dinosaurs yeah
sci-fi get on that movie yeah i want to
see that nazi dinosaurs
i can imagine the little tyrannosauruses
with their tiny little swastika things
on their
tiny little arms and they've got jets
they've got jets and ufos
i like it in antarctica okay
i would be i'm i'm gonna say right now
i'd be very surprised if somebody hadn't
already made that movie
yeah i'm just gonna i'm gonna google it
after the show and i'm gonna see if
somebody actually made it
out there he's saying his take on it
just that with the crucifixion is that
something happened and it resonated with
the masses
my response is no what happened was is
that
that narrative happened that they
started to build up that kind of
narrative around the third century a.d
in rome and they were saying that it
happened about 200
something years in the past
and they're saying that jesus was an
actual character
and don't listen to the other christians
with the other suppers
and with the other jesuses that were not
born of a woman
that that's no it's too fishy they were
just trying to get a leg up on like the
other denominations yeah there were
other denominations they had different
versions of jesus so they had to have
like a better story
you're right and the only reason why we
know of it is not because it's spread by
some kind of a
you know what i mean resonation with the
masses no it's not what happened
it was the backing of the roman
government it was the rom it was the
religion of the roman
the new roman government in the third
century that's why
well and i feel like too it's like if
you have the
power and the money behind you to like
back a particular um
you know agenda and you also have the
power and authority to
kill people that don't agree with you
yeah then you can pretty easily like
spread a thing and then like a few
hundred years from now there'll be
nobody left that remembers like all
because you killed all the people that
disagreed
yeah it only takes a few generations in
a time when there's no internet or
any kind of [ __ ] uh mass media
you can get people to believe in a new
truth
very quickly and you're taught it
no it's just it just didn't happen
there's too many there's there's too
many problems with the story
um it was brought in it was brought into
belief into common belief
because of backing of the roman empire
it was the original
it was it was the official religion of
the late roman empire
uh it replaced all other religions and
it was a way to help unite the empire in
a time of civil war
that had a lot to do with it it outlived
the roman empire
yeah clearly because we're still talking
about it so
it was well made in its day and very
powerful
although they weren't thinking of that
back then they were just thinking of
like the immediate immediate
problem it evolved and changed a lot
over 2 000 years
which you know everything will now
i'm not like i said i'm not discounting
that somebody might have
uh made the shroud with a camera obscura
because i've seen like
other people that made ones like that
with the camera obscura and it looked
pretty good
i'm kind of gonna say though i subscribe
to i think that the person that made it
either made it with um a bar relief
statue like that was kind of flat or
made it with a dead body or another kind
of statue
and they kind of just like they took the
linen and they kind of put it over
the thing and then they took some paint
and just like scrubbed it on there kind
of
like it like you would do a gravestone
rubbing like i kind of feel like that
was probably
how i mean i
because of the weirdness and the
proportions i kind of feel like they
didn't use
a real model or a or a corpse which some
people have said that they use like a
real dead body
i don't think they did because i think
that you know the head being a little
bit too big the arms being a little bit
too long
i think they probably used um you know a
mannequin or a statue
or something like that because that
would be to me that seems like the
easiest thing because if you're gonna do
a camera obscura
you know when they did it nowadays like
in the present day it took them like
more than a month like in a month and a
half
like to expose the [ __ ] for long enough
to like get an image and even then the
image was very
vague i mean you could still see that it
was a dude
but yeah you know um i kind of feel like
the easiest way to
make something like that would be to use
like
a mannequin or like a statue of some
kind that would lay there still
you could put a piece of linen over it
and then you could just take a brush
that was kind of like had some red ochre
or something like that and just kind of
scrub it
and it would make like like i said like
a rubbing it would just like kind of hit
the high points
and it would kind of look like and then
later you could kind of come back and
get some vermilion or something like
that and kind of like paint some blood
on there
and then be like ta-da it's like it's
let me respond to louis all right louie
louie's saying that in the for um
he said constantine the great
constantine the great made christianity
the official religion of the roman
empire um
actually that's the official story but
there's
there's some people that think that
maybe that's not really what happened
we know that constantine the great made
christianity
legal because before that time it was
illegal
but everything that constantine the
great built the monuments and [ __ ] was
purely pagan
so he didn't seem to be a christian this
whole idea of him
seeing a cross in the sky and converting
to christianity
seems to be a story that was made up a
lot later all right
he was a pagan or you know he believed
in the roman gods
uh it's just that it seems to be that
later christians are honoring him
you know what i mean yeah as the as like
the
he was the guy that was the guy that
made it official okay
but some people are thinking now it
might have happened about 100 years
after that actually
he just made it legal and allowed it to
grow
it's kind of like well here's the thing
thank you very much matt
thanks pat but here's the thing when
you're looking back at history
it's very easy for history to become i
guess compressed for lack of a better
word
because i used to think about this all
the time when i was a kid because i was
really into dinosaurs like a lot of kids
are
and you would think about like really
the really cool dinosaurs like t-rex and
like you know [ __ ] ankylosaurus and
all these other different ones
and then you would find out much later
on that a lot of these dinosaurs didn't
actually live at the same time and it
was like millions of years between them
but because you live now and a human
lifetime is relatively
you know in terms of geological time
very short yeah you know
you're depressing yeah you don't realize
that like some of those dinosaurs were
like millions of years extinct before
this other dinosaur even evolved and
they didn't even live at the same time
or even like
millions of years between them so it's
like that kind of blows our minds to
think about
so i kind of feel like the same thing
happens with history yeah
where you're looking back at like
biblical times you're looking back at
the middle ages or whatever
but you have to understand that like
some of the [ __ ] that was happening
like with the biblical books with you
know [ __ ] that happened in the middle
ages
it was hundreds of years yeah between
some of those occurrences
hundreds of years i think what happened
is constantine made it legal
once it was legal it started to grow um
and then maybe a generation or two it
started to get maybe government backing
and then it really started to expand
and then in hindsight they go back and
start claiming christianity as being
older than it really is
you know emperor constantine he was the
one that [ __ ] did this and that
when nah probably wasn't you know well
everything is approved
everything is always more another thing
too is another thing
um is that a lot of things are more
complex than they say
because there's this there's a lot of
these stories about well constantine's
mom was a christian and this and that
and during the civil wars
he decided to throw his lot behind
christianity which helped him win this
those stories seem to have come a lot
later as like rationalizations
yeah of why he but they're evidently
evidently they can't really prove that
that's the truth probably legend
yeah probably legend yeah because
doesn't it sound kind of convenient
yeah you got a guy like i like i said a
lot yeah and like everybody knows who
constantine is right
right you know and it and and a lot of a
lot of skeptics
who are really you know [ __ ] big into
roman history are kind of like going nah
that doesn't really jive
with the with that that story doesn't
really jive with the archaeology
of the [ __ ] that you dig up yeah and
that's what really that's where your
real proof is
yeah i mean archaeology yeah that's kind
of what every monument constantine built
was purely pagan there's no christian
symbolism on it at all yeah and you know
i mean so
so either he was just paying lip service
or that was like
posthumously like i think he was
possibly put on him
because he made christianity legal
yeah so then a couple generations later
you got christians thinking that
hey he was he was a christian which that
doesn't necessarily follow right he
might have just been like yeah i don't
really care whatever
i think he made it legal because it was
nothing more than just one of the other
religions in rome why that's what i mean
maybe it didn't
it would bother him he was just like
yeah whatever just do what you want
right maybe it was just that and so
they're like well they had other
they had retroactively like assigning
him christianity yeah
and well here's another thing that
[ __ ] is constantly christians throw
around and it's even in history it's in
roman history
all this stuff about burning christians
at the stake along the via opia
and christians being [ __ ] accused of
burning down rome and all this kind of
stuff and being killed by the lions in
in the [ __ ] um
uh in in the coliseum
a lot of these historians that know rome
[ __ ] super well think that all that's
[ __ ]
yeah that is made up i mean that is
exaggerated at best
exaggerated [ __ ] rome was secular and
tolerant of other christian
other uh of other religions they didn't
seem to have anything against christians
the only thing we do know is like i
think it was in i think
it might have been josephus he just kind
of throws christianity in as being kind
of like a ridiculous superstition kind
of like the beliefs of addis
and addis was [ __ ] cutting off your
own dick that was [ __ ] really
ridiculous yeah like it wasn't anything
different to them no
yeah and they just thought it was
something kind of ridiculous and that uh
and some actual writings say that when
rome burned
during the time of nero that christians
were like
at the forefront of helping to fight the
fire so that
totally goes against the de and that
wrong that nero thanked them
which that totally goes against the
narrative of christians being like a
picked on
[ __ ] here's the and like more in the
ma
martyr tradition yeah say we were picked
on like i said no offense but i do feel
like there's a long tradition in
christianity of
persecution they want it yeah all right
they all want to feel like they're
persecuted
because they because that gives them
like a sanctity yeah
maybe all of the religions are like that
mormonism we were picked on
judaism we were picked on islam we were
picked on
all religions we were picked on oh yeah
well yeah i mean the victim narrative is
very powerful very powerful
okay and you can take it to extremes
nazis
their whole thing was we were picked on
when you really [ __ ] analyzed what
they were saying
they were picking on us good
oracle makes a very good point if you're
persecuted you're not a loser
you're a martyr yeah exactly exactly
exactly that's why i feel like a lot of
a lot of groups that are actually quite
powerful
like to adopt the victim narrative
because
that's why it makes them feel like like
you know we don't have power
we don't we're [ __ ] just everyone's
picking on them in the case of early
christian romans though i don't think
they were picked on
at all i think they were just another
one of the groups i think the truth of
it is that they were ignored
and that nobody noticed them they seemed
to be very yeah that seemed to
seem to be a very small group that
nobody really noticed
that they weren't getting in trouble so
they weren't talked about
that's yeah so they had to come up with
something you had to come up with
people to pay attention well once you
have no once you once you're a big
religion with state backing you have to
[ __ ] make a history for yourself
yeah of where you came from and and it's
always a very popular narrative is that
oh you know what
we used to be picked on but finally they
overcoming adversity is something that a
lot of people
like and a lot of people can relate to
they used to throw us to the lines in
the arena there's no records of that
they only threw criminals in the in yeah
i mean and there are no roman accounts
of christians being thrown in there only
criminals and enemies of the state
but they were not specified as you know
i mean they're talking about
you know they're talking about thracians
right i mean they could have been
christians but yeah i don't think that
there was like a you know a codified
kind of like thing it's like me let's
throw the christians and then the roman
christian mythos when it they talk about
being thrown to the lions for their
religion but it's only in the christian
tradition not in the roman tradition
right and i think the romans would have
talked about them
if they were so so much of a threat that
they had to throw into the alliance
and there would have been millions of
them right yeah and that's not what
they're saying
so it's a pseudo history yeah
it's a pseudo history well as i said i
feel like a lot of people and
like i said i do believe that somewhere
among
everyone's perceptions there is an
objective truth
but most people and this is very human
everyone does it
but you do want to cast your history
in the best possible light like to make
yourself
look better yeah than possibly so i do
feel like that there's kind of like that
there there's really that thing like
among these groups where they always
want to make their history look like
look we overcome
we overcame like all of this like [ __ ]
they were against us and we john's going
josephus came after nero of course he
did
of course josephus came up in here
josephus mentions christians evidently
or supposedly
in the damn josephine super statement
although some of that was later
it was later added that was added later
but after joseph
but i'm pretty sure he also i think
that's where that one reference of
christianity comes from i think it was
from antiquities of the jews
i have to double check but i think he
mentions just a very small paragraph
and he kind of throws them in with addis
but doesn't give very many details i
think it was josephus maybe i'm
might have been sway tony at sweetonious
but i don't know i have to go back and
look at it
but he does make the [ __ ] josephus
the josephine super statement
about you know i mean jesus jesus of uh
was he called jesus of nazareth if we
may call him a man
and all in all the great works that he
did blah blah
that and that's not in the earlier
editions of it well the weird thing
about that particular
is it even a paragraph it's just like a
couple of sentences
yeah it kind of feels like it's like an
advertisement yeah it's just like stuck
in the middle of [ __ ]
that it wasn't really it doesn't really
belong in there it was an insertion
i yeah and not a very good one either
because it really it didn't even like
it didn't even like make an effort to
fit in with the rest of the text or
whatever the topic was that they were
talking about
like you like you said they stuck it in
like a commercial yeah well it fulfills
it fulfills catholicism too yeah and
legitimizes [ __ ] roman catholicism
but as you said i feel like the people
that did that
they believed it wouldn't have thought
they were doing anything bad
because they would have justified it by
saying well we're bringing more people
to
the truth or how you know however they
understood it
so it's like they didn't really feel
like they were fooling anybody or doing
anything like
i think what they were doing is they
were reading through there and they go
hey wait a minute
this is the place where he should have
been talking about jesus yeah jesus
christ
that's what they did write that down
we're going to put that right in we're
going to put him here where's the best
place to put this
okay that doesn't sound like you had a
place actually it was kind of in a place
it was
timeline wise that would have been
around 30 a.d
so there that's why they put it there
timeline wise but
in the flow of the text no it didn't
make any sense it doesn't make it no it
doesn't make sense
it just it sounds like you're reading
the [ __ ] and then suddenly
hey come buy some tires it was kind of
like that it was like
it was like an ad in the middle of this
they read josephus history book and it
was well detailed he talked about a
bunch of other cults and a bunch of
other [ __ ] that was long forgotten
and they [ __ ] read it and after a
couple generations of reading that
somewhere in the [ __ ] fifth or sixth
century
they went where the [ __ ] is jesus
there's no jesus in here yeah he didn't
talk about jesus
he missed it well we'll help him out
there's a reason why why he didn't talk
about jesus because nobody
there there was no jesus no well like i
said it's like
and like i said no offense to anybody
but it's like i'm really
kind of jesus was the angel gabriel it
was the angel gabriel's big brother
that's what they're
talking about yeah he was a mythical
figure
like a greek god or something like that
and then angel moroni as the time went
on they wanted to humanize him
to make him more appealing it was called
euhemorization
yeah and it's because they believed that
well they wanted to make him into a
person so
the people could relate to him and it
was a common thing that they did
yeah it's a very common thing that they
did
yeah okay and like i said i do feel like
people and
people are still doing it nowadays
because i can't believe
i still can't believe that people are
still debating
whether the shroud of turin is real or
not
like if it actually like wrapped around
the body but you like i said i don't
think jesus was a real person anyway
obviously since i don't believe he's a
real person i don't believe in the
resurrection i don't believe in any of
that stuff
so the fact that people are still
debating about the reality of it
even after it's been carbon 14 david
eden you know dated even after all of
the scientific [ __ ] that's been done on
it
like people are still talking about it
like it's some big mystery
that's like mind-blowing to me but you
know i do find it interesting in the
sense that like i said i'm really into
art forgeries
um we should do a show about hans van
meegeren now i'm thinking about it
because he's my favorite art forger
but um i've read like a bunch of books
about him because he was a fascinating
dude but so i'm interested in like the
methods by which it was pulled off
i'm more interested in that than i am in
people trying to do like apologetics
about why
all the scientific [ __ ] is wrong why
this is actually
the [ __ ] about gamma rays that was just
that was the top for me i was just kind
of like i'm reading this book i'm like
reading i'm watching all these
documentaries about it
and the fact that a guy can come out and
say with a straight face
that he thought the image was put on the
cloth
by gamma rays of all things and then
it's like i'm not even sure if this was
the same guy
but there was another guy that said
there was something about and he wrote
some kind of like scientific quote
unquote paper
where he was talking about oh well maybe
the rocks of the tomb were like
the the way they pressed together and
like they made this kind of like
field or something and i'm just like are
you [ __ ]
serious right now like what the [ __ ] you
were talking about it's like it just
seems like
the worst kind of [ __ ] reaching ken
fetter is asking me if
i think they're the greek gods were real
all right bro oh wait um
sean says christopher hitchens explains
religion the best i yeah i agree with
you i don't i don't agree with
christopher hitchens on some [ __ ]
but he was uh he was pretty spot on with
but i've got a bunch of his books like
back there on the shelf so i'm just
saying
can the greek gods
and the old testament gods are the same
gods
it's just that the old testament gods
are hillbilly versions of it
yeah they just changed the name pretty
much the same you have el shaddai
okay and then all his sons he has 72
sons there were 72 virgins but there
were also 72
sons and yahweh chosen thank you matt
all right
greetings el shaddai it means father of
the gods
that's that's zeus look at all these
little gods
and then it says that
yahweh chose israel okay but then later
on it also
says that the sons of god el shaddai's
sons
okay these 72 of them they saw the
daughters of women and found them
beautiful
and [ __ ] had children with them and
they were called the nephilim
the same [ __ ] was happening over on
mount olympus okay
zeus jumping down and having sex with
women perseus popping up
the nephilim just means demigods all
right you're this is this
the the greeks and the middle eastern
people and the persian people were
all of part of the same diaspora and it
was all kind of different versions of
the same
religion even the persians
were persians because they worshipped
perseus okay
they're all the you know that this old
testament [ __ ] is just a hillbilly
version of the [ __ ] gods on mount
olympus that's all it is
[ __ ] judea
and all that [ __ ] that's the mississippi
of europe okay
actually around the wild lands accurate
yeah that's all it is
okay just have a slight different take
on it so
were the greek gods real or well
are the old testament gods real [ __ ] no
they're all like equally they're about
the same they're all equally fake
and in fact all things are the
imagination when i was a kid
studying greek and roman mythology was
one of the things that brought me to
atheism
yeah was because it occurred to me when
i was
10 11 years old when i was reading about
greek myths i was like
you know people used to believe this
[ __ ] was real just like people nowadays
believe christianity was real and i made
the connection in my mind like variance
now there's a process called
euhemorization where people would take
these gods
and make them real people on earth and
even the ancient egyptian
ancient greeks were doing that ancient
greek historians
and ancient greek philosophers and
intellectuals
were saying things like well there must
have been a zeus
and there must have been a hera but what
they're talking about is a great ancient
king that inspired these stories
and his great wife or queen that
inspired these stories
so they must be based in things that
actually happened
they were just turned into gods
no not at all see that people will pull
[ __ ] out of that no that's
that logic does not follow like yeah i'm
i'm a fiction writer
people can just pull [ __ ] out of their
ass yeah that doesn't mean
like look my mom read some of my horror
stories and she's like what happened to
you that you wrote about this kind of
stuff i'm like mom
i made it up yeah you just make it up it
doesn't have anything to do with any
real [ __ ]
that happened to you it doesn't it
things don't have to be based on reality
you can imagine
things and just because just because
religion is a genre of literature that
doesn't mean
anything super super
hero comics are a genre of literature
star wars is a genre of literature
okay just because there is a darth vader
and an emperor that does not mean that
that was based on real historical people
they're kind of like character
archetypes yeah
and those things have always existed
going back to the [ __ ]
well like i said human brains are only
so we're not unlimited
like we can only think about x number of
things yeah
so and it's like everybody on earth we
all evolved from the same
you know species so all our brains are
like pretty similar
and work in similar ways so we come up
with similar
stories because that's just the way our
brains now let me [ __ ] you people up i'm
gonna [ __ ] y'all people up
star wars the original trilogy
is that true did that [ __ ] happen no
that [ __ ] didn't happen
but is it true yeah [ __ ] star wars is
true
[ __ ] right star wars is true every
little [ __ ] tale
and every little lesson in there is
something that you could learn from and
it's a true
it's a truism that's the way all these
it's mythology
that's the way all these mythological
nice thing about mythology is that it
doesn't have to be
literally true it's fig it's
mythologically true figuratively
it's emotionally emotional getting to
something that
is at the heart of all people which is
why it still resonates
yeah that's why i'm not a true i'm not
an atheist i'm a mythicist
i like that [ __ ] i know it's [ __ ]
but i also know that it's valuable
and just like what joseph campbell says
there's a power to mythology
i got khan of otzlan in there listening
to me mesoamerican [ __ ] on the
top of a damn
pyramid cutting people's hearts out
throwing children into the cenote
he understands he understands
tales have a certain power to them
okay he know you know it's true and
religions are like that
now just because it's not true doesn't
mean it isn't useful
i think that's a good way to yeah those
are two completely different concepts
i mean having a background in the
infantry
do or die type [ __ ] put [ __ ] rolling
the dice with your [ __ ] nuts on the
table you may die
today that type of mentality i just
better have a mythology that you operate
from
you will not have the strength to face
death
without a certain type of [ __ ]
mythology to help you through it
it just won't happen i don't know i have
that i i don't have that but
i'm a vulcan yeah you don't have any
emotion i use the emotion
i channel the [ __ ] emotion you know
what i mean
but [ __ ] you see me turn tvs on and
move objects just with emotions which
reminds you
just emotion i don't even think it's my
mind it's like spiritual emotion
so it is very powerful that's why i said
the things in star wars are true
you could do better [ __ ] than tournament
tv i'm old i'm old now make some money
up here or something you have to build
up so much inner conflict
you have to build up so much inner
conflict to do something
to make [ __ ] weird [ __ ] happen it's
just like in star trek where
the emperor says go to the jedi temple
we must catch them off guard
and after you've killed all the children
then you will be strong enough
in the dark side to save padme
that's the kind of [ __ ] they uh i i
believe today the thing about like
[ __ ]
hayden christensen was like okay they
could have played that [ __ ] so [ __ ]
bad it's so [ __ ] awesome
the sad thing is like that dude is
actually a good actor and i feel like
everybody got it was kind of like the
you know it was kind of like um you know
robert pattinson
like what's her face from [ __ ]
twilight they were in those horrible
movies and like they kind of got like
[ __ ] on as being terrible
actors but then you see them and other
stuff and they're [ __ ] awesome yeah
cause like was it kristen stewart she
was in underwater
robert pattinson was in the lighthouse
you know i was just gonna say somebody
said that we should build a cult to
pokey
and jenna blana said pookie first of her
name short of tale
ravager of envelopes but what's funny
about what's funny about mythology and
what seems to be true
based upon my experience as my own
personal experiences
that stories about witches stories about
satanists and weird [ __ ] warlocks and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that always has to do
with
doing things to other people that you
don't want to do or don't like to do
to cause inner conflict and self-hatred
there's something about that self-hatred
that can somehow manifest itself and
just
i want to say some kind of weird psionic
abilities
that can do damage to people
yeah i get that that's what they're
talking about well because
if your um if your supposition is true
that
it is this emotional turmoil that causes
this kind of
yeah poltergeist activity cultural term
then it would behoove oneself
to do evil yeah well or to do evil and
to feel bad
about it right and you have to not just
do evil and not give a [ __ ] right
that wouldn't work and you have to you
have to have enough intellect to grasp
the evil right okay now
to go the other way all right like say
like what a jedi would do
you wouldn't gain that type of effect
it would be more about what you hear
about like healing and giving people
inner peace
maybe seeing the future slightly or help
it be you know more beneficial less
physical more esoteric [ __ ]
but whenever i hear these stories about
sith and [ __ ] possession and
poltergeist and [ __ ] warlocks
the effects that they do are always
physical and it's always damaging
it's something you can fight with
yeah yeah i mean that's what's being
described in the stories
now where are these stories coming from
is this some kind of like
an inner knowledge is that that somehow
manifests itself in the imagination
maybe is there something instinctual
that even a person who just writes
fiction
can somehow or is are they following
traditions
literary traditions to make stories like
this
or or what i don't know where it's
coming from as i said i feel like
you know i feel like i can kind of weigh
in on this a little bit as somebody that
writes
right fiction and has never done
anything
super horrible in my real life but has
written about many horrible things in my
fiction
like i said my mom was horrified when
she read my stuff and she thought that i
was working from some
because i guess some people think that
you have to experience something in real
life or
you know to like write about it but you
don't
you can totally put yourself into that
mindset if you
already you know if you're imaginative
to imaginative enough to like put
yourself into that mindset
so i'm a good person i haven't done
anything like really horrible than
anyone else that i know of
um but i'm really good at putting myself
into really like horrifying situations
and like
seeing how it would play out like in my
mind i don't want to do it in real life
i'm
you know what i'm nothing like that but
i don't know like i feel like you don't
you don't have to like really experience
that kind of [ __ ] too
imagination is sufficient i think you
know what i mean
to kind of get a feel for that kind of
stuff people are mentioning
l ron hubbard yeah it's funny he he
wrote shitty sci-fi evidently
but he's not writing his stuff so i'm
like i'm not i've heard that it's shitty
but i'm not gonna
judge because i haven't read it in some
ways l ron hubbard is talking about what
i was talking about basically
yeah it makes me wonder if if if
george lucas somehow maybe read some l
ron hubbard
and well a lot of people did because he
was a very popular
sci-fi writer before hit like the whole
scientology thing really took hold
makes me wonder maybe if star wars was
also kind of
influenced by [ __ ] lrh i don't know
everything's influenced by everything
i mean that's the thing it's like nobody
and like i said i'm coming at it from
like a writer's standpoint you can't
you know you can't have read everything
i try to read a lot but
you can't read everything you know
from all time ever so it's kind of like
you're basically going to repeat ideas
because as i said human brains are
amazing but they're also very limited in
the paths that they can go down
and humans will go down a certain number
of
pathways because that's just what we're
programmed to do
how long we've been talking um two hours
and 30 minutes how much is left on the
material
well i don't know we still haven't even
talked about any of the others oh [ __ ]
okay i'm gonna go to the restaurant
a second you're gonna you want me to do
commercials do the commercials because i
kind of gotta pee too
all right so we're gonna do some
commercials so we can both go to the
bathroom oh there's pookie see she
didn't get cooked
why did somebody suggest that it's
terrible now i'm like thinking about
that and i'm thinking about that one
bedroom movie where that like poor kitty
got like baked in the oven and it like
really traumatized me
that's why i saw that in the trailer and
i didn't want to i didn't want to watch
that movie
but it was a good movie though we
reviewed it but yeah so we're gonna do
some uh
commercials and uh gonna go to the
bathroom i got some pookie videos i got
some commercials i got all kind of other
[ __ ]
so we'll be back in just a few minutes
so you know hang in there we'll be uh
back in a minute join us september 25th
26th and 27th for a three-day special
streaming event
strange realities to push the limits of
your
reality featuring authors academics
researchers occultists experiencers
podcasters and practitioners
all presenting fresh cutting-edge
material and research
david metcalf fighter and researcher
alan greenfielder of secret cipher of
the euphemism
timothy ritter host of strange familiars
dombrowski author and practitioner rick
bishop author of
project theta jenny ashford host of 13
o'clock
recluse toast of the farm jack
montgomery filth magic
joshua cutchen author of these in the
night reverend michael carter
alien contact experiencer dr future host
of feature
tony kale author of memphis hoodoo and
ryan collier occultist
soraya askow host of word of the road go
john tanning ghost stalkers and help
all three days only 20 tickets and info
available at strange
realitiesconference.com
brought to you by the conspiranormal
podcast conspiranol.com
strange realities
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case the frog
boys
the alcasar murders and the anoka shira
park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
hi sweetie what you doing what you doing
she's like why are you filming me i'm
not doing anything
look she's when mommy's not in the bed
she sleeps in the bed
because i was actually working late last
night because i was on a radio show
i was up till 11 when i came in to go to
sleep tom was already asleep and she was
sleeping on my side of the bed
she jumped out when i got a shower
you're such a good girl
you're sleeping on mommy's side of the
bed oh my goodness
i know you have such a rough life i was
yawning and sleepy
you're so cute yeah
okay i'll let you go back to sleep we
gotta go to the store anyway
okay okay she's like i'm not talking to
you anymore
all right so uh tom hasn't come back
from the [ __ ]
kitchen yet what are you doing in there
okay here are you
where's spooky sleeping in the damn boat
she's sleeping sleeping well she's
pretending to sleep in a bowl every time
i walk by she looks like this was that
pokey and she's like
normally she would be asking to go out
on the porch at this time jesus
because it's 7 20. she's sleeping all
day she knows it's raining
oh yeah she knows it's raining she's
like oh i'm gonna get wet although she
doesn't really mind getting wet does she
she'll go run around in the rain and
then she comes in she's like yeah i'm
all wet and stinky
deal with it
sunrise yeah you did yeah i didn't want
to open up another whole bottle of that
bottle do you want to open up a whole
can a damn rock star
bottle just for a half a drink because a
rock star will make a whole [ __ ]
jar of that [ __ ] tracerender666 says
tom is the funniest man on youtube no
[ __ ] stop it
i'm probably listening i'm the [ __ ]
clown of this show
yeah yeah i mean i don't know i feel bad
because i feel like i'm funny too but
i feel like it gets kind of kind of lost
you know what i mean in the whole well
you got [ __ ] you got to do
yeah yeah i'm i'm like the i'm like the
workhorse i'm the one that's like
working behind this look at trying to
get us trying to [ __ ] get you
people i want you guys to send jenny a
[ __ ] super chat
she gets all the money i just come in
here and just [ __ ] around really i was
working on well because
i mean sophie is coming to visit us next
yeah next less than a week away yeah
sophie's going to be a [ __ ] special
guest
so i was kind of two weeks she she'll be
on the show yeah so she's going to be on
all her live streams like after
the 18th i guess you guys gotta love
sophie she's
yeah she's ready she's cool yeah she
came and visited us before yeah
and um so i'm like okay well all the
[ __ ] that's got to be recorded
like all my like book reviews all my
like um
you know my witching hour shows i wanted
to do like all of those like ahead of
time so we didn't
so i didn't have to do them while she
was here so i could hang out with her
more
um so i've been like really trying to
like work on those like [ __ ] all day
and then like last night i was doing the
radio show and that was like a last
minute
thank you matt thanks matt he was having
flashbacks matt
that was like a last minute thing like
tim benall like contacted me like a day
or two before and he was like hey it's
like i hate to like this is so last
minute but can you please be on the show
like friday night
and i was like sure and then he sent me
a list like the day of the show
like can you talk about this this this
and this and so i had to like read
through my books again to like
refresh all the so i was in here like he
kept coming in the office like
are you like ever coming into the
bedroom or are you ever gonna say i was
like no because i gotta like read
through all these notes i gotta be on
the show it's like
i don't wanna sound like an idiot on
there but the show came out good i
thought
yeah it this whole [ __ ] project
worked out good though because you see
jenny was
stuck in a graphic design job this is
back in the old economy when people
[ __ ] had to go to work
and i had to go somewhere else to work
and then you worked for pennies
you know based on what you were they
were making a lot of money off you
yeah well i have to say i've been okay
so i graduated from college
in 1997.
so i've been a graphic designer for more
than 20 years
thank you very much victor thank you
victor
and um honestly i know this is florida
and the pay is really crap down here
um i never made more than 15
an hour being a graphic designer ever
um the only way like i made my bills
was by freelancing on the side and doing
other [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying they're making
fun of me remember what top said
gorillas
were good people i think gorillas aren't
good people girls are good people
they're watching they're better they're
better than most humans i feel like
well better than a lot of humans let's
say that not most humans
i can read eyes and i just saw gorillas
do their thing you know with
people and other gorillas and i said man
gorillas are good people man
you know they're people they're just a
different kind of people
you know i'm just that's what i'm saying
i've watched kind of yeah i'm thinking
like i gave them
the people moniker yes people well
honestly any of the great apes
um i've seen like in [ __ ] zoos and
stuff like i've been at animal kingdom
i've been a lot [ __ ]
and you watch like gorillas you watch
chimps and stuff
um they know what's going on you look at
them in the face
yeah that is like looking at a person
yeah
they got one down in japan they should
probably not be locked up
you can look him up on youtube they got
one down in japan his young
male gorilla and he's got all these
japanese female fans that come and
[ __ ] show pit you know
with pictures and [ __ ] they love that
they think this is the sexiest gorilla
ever they're kind of sexy and he's
sitting there and he poses for
him yeah i saw i saw [ __ ] i saw a
gorilla at animal kingdom doing that as
well
he definitely knows that these japanese
girls are flirting with him and he's
sitting there just basking in it
and he's trying to show his good side
and he's doing these
he's doing male behavior yep and and he
knows that these
that's why i think that they should not
be put in zoos
because i was in i was at animal kingdom
and this was um
probably 10 or 11 years ago i was at
animal kingdom and i was in the
guerrilla enclosure you can kind of go
through this underground thing and
there's these big glass windows and you
can watch
like all the gorillas and stuff and the
gorilla i was like watching him
and he very deliberately like walk to
the back of the enclosure there was kind
of a tree in a little hill there
and he he very deliberately laid down on
the hill
and he goes
yeah just like that like while everybody
was like looking at him and he's like
yeah
drank me in he was just like exactly
like that yeah
and like his body language his facial
expressions
everything was very very human and in
that moment
i felt i laughed but i felt really
really bad that he was
like in custody yeah this whole thing
about not being in zoos though that's an
outmoded view though because well it
depends on what the zoo
is like yeah because i guess yeah i've
been to some zoos
where because honestly i'm not going to
name them that's really the only safe
place for them
right now because they're being they're
just their habitat is small if you were
to
empty all the zoo gorillas particularly
gorillas yeah if you were to empty all
the gorillas out into the into their
real environment in africa they'd be
overpopulated they'd be hunted near
extinction they eat up all the food
because there's a breeding population in
captivity that's pretty big
and that's that's really the only way
they're going to survive human
civilization
is to be in captivity i'm just saying
that species won't survive
if they have to be in captivity um
animal kingdom is like actually pretty
good because they actually have very
large you know environments from the
kind of approximates their natural
environment which you know that's fine
um but i have been to some zoos i'm not
naming which ones
but i have been to some zoos where they
kept some animals in
cages and like little tiny yeah that's
not good because yeah
which there's
[ __ ] huge tracks of land here in the
united states where they need to [ __ ]
take a lot of these things they just
make a preserve
yeah you keep them you keep them fenced
in so they can't get out but there's a
lot of places
there's still a lot of land in the
united states yeah it's a bit there's a
lot of
and canada is vast it's a little cold
there but you could give them a place to
go when it gets for winter
yeah depending on the species they go in
there yeah but
africa is not safe for them it's just
not i looked at the situation on the
ground no
they're just getting poached yeah
humans are encroaching on them yeah i've
read a couple books about
um you know gorilla species there and
like people that were like working with
the gorillas there
and yeah it's not like there's there's
reserves there
yeah which you know fine but the only
way that those preserves can survive
is by like tourists coming from the west
like that want to see gorillas and they
come and they pay and they come to like
there's pookie come up here sweetie i'd
have those i'd have those gorillas all
moved to brazil
plenty of land in brazil or they can run
right in our yard
just keep him i don't [ __ ] uh-uh
dudes let me in the house i'll have to
let him in the house he's bigger than me
and then he [ __ ] goes where's the
fridge at
and i [ __ ] take him over the fridge
and he's like how much beer you got left
it's like bears that like
well the bears in the neighborhood here
they like go in people's garage and be
like what you got in the fridge
we pulled up one night [ __ ] was
coming up in the driveway and a big ass
[ __ ] bear [ __ ] bigger than me
sitting there on the ground with his
feet in the driveway
sitting in the driveway looking at me i
said dude what are you doing he got up
because [ __ ] i'm out of here
nothing i was just sitting here and
driving away but now you're right
like a kid the [ __ ] was big man he's
about six feet tall
and like i said they know how to open
fridges they know how to open car doors
yeah so you know they don't like they
don't want to hurt anybody they just
want food
they're smarter than a dog yeah in
between a dog and a chimp
i mean i'm not scared of them anymore
that i'm let's get to the [ __ ] story
man we're going on these damn
so we all right so what's spooky doing
back there oh she's playing with them
with the one envelope yeah like [ __ ]
with she was asking for more envelopes
the other day no
you can have that one yeah because
you've already torn that one up
and i can't use it michael's talking
about
monkeys in the windows of the pet store
beating off all day long yeah they do
that
yeah that was another thing that like i
i love the way you go
to like animal kingdom or somewhere like
that and it's like you can't stop the
monkeys from
masturbating or from [ __ ] one another
and like i love
that families come there they're looking
through the glass and like the little
five-year-old kid is like asking his
parents what are they doing mommy
they're they're playing they love each
other and they're playing
which i love i [ __ ] love that all
right so can i go to the bathroom now
oh you can go because i didn't no
because i didn't have time
okay because i thought you were running
the commercials good i was running the
commercials but
you've got to talk i gotta talk they're
gonna make me talk to these people
okay good you're good at that right go
ahead yeah okay
look at her look at her okay
all right let's see what's going on
everybody all right so i got the show
i'm at the [ __ ]
i'm at the helm can't go as
relaxed tom remember your bp what's a bp
i thought bp british petroleum
what you doing pope
yeah but i wouldn't uh you know some
people are like anti-zoo
some of those animals are [ __ ]
endangered they're you know where they
are in their environments they're being
encroached on by humans
and then the land can't support them
there's not enough of their natural
habitat left
so it's kind of like those tigers like i
wasn't big into [ __ ] old tiger man
but he had a lot of tigers those tigers
never would have lived you know
um you can't release that many tigers
they
they'd [ __ ] the land can't support
them so a lot of these animals are
just gonna be bred in captivity and kept
in captivity
um they just gotta make sure that the
laws are
set up in the way to where the animal
lives in a good habitat
you know that's that's the only way yeah
she's back
well yeah i'm not camping out in there i
just had to go to the bathroom
what's she doing poke she's tearing that
envelope up and then she's like sitting
on it
thank you mark
we should pay the animals wait what
zoo should pay the animals so we can tax
them
i don't know i'm very i'm ambivalent
about zoos like in some ways i think
they're good
if they are if they have sufficient
space
to provide habitat for the animals and
provide care for them
but if you're just gonna like cram them
in some tiny cage and like
make money off a bunch of yokels coming
to see them then yeah that's not good
i'm talking about my blood pressure now
my blood pressure is good now
is it have you have you checked it
lately oh man last time i checked it
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] good
i still take the blood pressure medicine
but i probably don't need it i really
just take it
because it [ __ ] um takes it gets rid
of your looks like a water pill
yeah i know and i look more handsome
with that [ __ ]
i took that on all of a sudden yeah
start getting like better definition and
[ __ ]
bodybuilders will take like a [ __ ]
big dose of that before they go to the
show and they piss out all their water
and then they can yeah and they like
don't drink
[ __ ] like look at my [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i'm really thirsty
yeah yeah really thirsty but i gotta do
this show
yeah i can't do that man they got
anorexia
i know i i have a thing where it's like
i drink like big every morning i come in
here i have a huge glass of water and i
refill it like many times during the day
so i drink a lot of water during the day
but i feel like i'm always thirsty
it was just probably not good that's
that's a symptom of diabetes but last
time i checked i
didn't have diabetes because it runs in
my family so i always get it checked
like every time i go for a
thing and i don't have it yet but yeah
we'll see
yeah but no um as soon as i started
lifting
um a couple years back the
blood pressure went back down to normal
my blood pressure has always been very
very low like dead person like yeah
you start lifting and you [ __ ] keep
in good shape your blood pressure stays
good at least
in my my case like a few times like when
i used to go to the doctor they'd be
like
is this even working like why i don't
know why
my blood pressure is just really low i
don't know what it is it must be like a
genetic thing
okay let's get back to the show so can
we talk about so we talked about
shroud of turin like i said i i feel
like
some artist did it with paint and either
a corpse or a bar relief
statue which is how i would have done it
if i was going to forge it
could have been done with a camera
obscura um that seems like a little more
trouble but i don't know if somebody was
into that kind of [ __ ] and they wanted
something
a little exotic that was good i think it
was a fake that
in its day was exotic it might have been
that it was made it more convincing that
it was that it was like some kind of
really [ __ ]
i think they knew it was fake but i
think i thought it was like a really
[ __ ] exotic fake
that would be like yeah like no one will
be able to figure out how to do that
because like a lot of people know about
yeah and then like uh
the guys uh you know the bishops and the
[ __ ] cardinals are looking at that
and they're going like
man that's [ __ ] awesome the [ __ ]
peasants i love that
that does look like like it's like a
soul bird that's
burned its way through there they're
like how much you offer that you know
that's that's exactly what i think well
because like i said that was kind of
your deal
when yeah you know and a lot of people
have pointed out like some people that
want the shroud to be real have pointed
out well
the wounds on the shroud are in the
wrists
when a lot of uh medieval art when a lot
of other art showed it through the hands
which obviously wouldn't have worked
because
if you put nails through the hands the
body would just fall off so you had to
like go through the [ __ ] wrists
um but i do feel like if somebody was
that invested
in making a really good fake that they
could get a lot of money for
then they would research that [ __ ] the
thing is is that people always worried
about hands or wrists or this and that
the crucifixion jesus didn't go through
a crucifixion there was no jesus this
was like
i'm just saying that whole thing is kind
of like because i don't really believe
that
i'm not saying that people weren't
crucified because they were they were
crucified but
they weren't crucified in the way that
christians showed it too they're showing
it on a t-shaped cross
in the first century romans did it on an
x
yeah and they probably weren't very high
up off the ground
and the foot was probably on some kind
of a [ __ ]
stand that i mean i don't think there
and they were lashed
to it and possibly nailed to it too at
the same time
but that stuff wasn't supporting all
their weight
there was something that they were
standing on in their feet yeah they
didn't want them falling off
because you could escape yeah you know
yeah cause like if
you just put it through your hands like
and you just like slipped off you'd be
like
bye so there's a lot of stuff
yeah and i i you know they usually were
you know like what isis would do they'd
be like
lash to it they weren't too [ __ ] high
off the ground they were guarded
because usually it took days to die yeah
there wasn't enough damage on them you
were there like almost as an example
yeah an example to like for other people
to look at
yeah it was people you know the idea was
is that people walked by and saw you and
you were [ __ ] suffering and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] punishment corporal punishment
or you know what a capital punishment
and where this is supposedly happening
you know golgotha and everything
they think they know where this is
um what you doing poop she's eating your
table
but but it you know evidently
i i don't know i don't probably don't
want to commit to that but
i was thinking that some of the stuff
that i've heard about you know it's kind
of
there's kind of conflicting information
to where that wasn't really where people
were executed
that was more like the garbage dump but
then they said well guy
gehan it is the garbage dump and then
other people are going well actually
that's more of a burial place
so the place where it's supposed to be
taking where it's be taken place you
know
golgotha that's where where it's
supposed to be take you know
happening i've heard that that's kind of
a sketchy location
like it probably didn't happen there um
because it didn't happen
from an archaeological standpoint they
can't really find a lot of
actually solid evidence of a lot of the
[ __ ] in the bible
i mean a lot of the [ __ ] that was
described in there they can't find any
archaeological whoever
whoever wrote the old the new testament
was kind of sketchy
about the geography of the area
yeah they're describing walking from one
place to another a lot
in just a few days when it would be more
like a week or so
or maybe like a couple weeks whoever's
telling these stories has never been to
these locations
but that checks out for like an early
you know second order it was like if you
were writing a story and you didn't do
like any research about the geography
it's like hey i'm writing a story about
like
this [ __ ] city in washington state
and i've never been there well how could
you do
research in those days i mean they
didn't even have real
good maps in those days well yeah
by the same extent like nobody that was
reading it could check up on your [ __ ]
yeah so you know you could write
whatever you wanted all these stories
became
more credible as time went on and things
were forgotten
it's like the holy land well where the
[ __ ] is this
nazareth was he from nazareth or is he
from bethlehem
or is he from judea well it's all
even though those are all different
places it was all the same place yeah
so you see jesus that was like the
suburbs or is he jesus from bethlehem
or is he or is he or is he you know is
he from the area of judea
now the the whole thing about
nazareth if i remember is that
there was some kind of a prophecy
um they were saying that
in the in the christian writings it says
that jesus was a nazarene basically
okay and i'm not even sure that might be
extra canonical now i'm not sure that's
in the canaan
and in the canon but jesus was it keeps
referring to jesus as
jesus the nazarene so
later you know early or
early christian or you know late roman
period christians
are going where the he's a nazarene
where the hell's nazareth
as if that's a place and most
most scholars now believe that nazarene
is not a place nazarene was a sect
it was a it was a sect of
proto-christians or late jews
so there was no nazareth now later on
there was like one of these roman
uh uh you know
it was it was the the the wife of a
roman emperor i think
i don't remember what her name was um
a man i almost said her name anyway
she set about on a [ __ ] ex on a
pilgrimage to fine
nazary to nazareth and
yeah and she did find a place and called
it nazareth and from here on out it's
called nazareth
well
it's like i'm gonna go find this place
hey here's this this is nazareth
this is the place i was looking for put
a sign there
because nobody knew where it was
in her day somebody in the audience
might know who it is i'm talking about
back in those days you could just pull
[ __ ] out of your ass
and nobody could check anything no this
shit's all legend
you know what i mean and then it was me
i feel like the longer ago
stuff was like the more like fiction and
non-fiction
believed into one another it became
historical as you started naming [ __ ]
after legend
and then now everybody's like oh
nazareth is right there
but it's like you know that place wasn't
named that until
yeah a lot lately a lot later and it was
just like random like somebody just came
to a place and was like yeah actually
she was a roman i think that was more
like the time of
i think that might have been i'm tired
i'm gonna stop for a snack this is
nazareth right here
i'm just i'm just saying that i'm kind
of drunk and it's and i haven't read
about it in a while
but if i remember actually i don't even
think she was rome and i think she was
more like from the holy roman empire
like one of constantine's [ __ ]
relatives not constantine what was his
name
um why are you hitting me i don't know
you know what i'm talking about
dude who had all the wives dude form the
[ __ ]
that's not narrowing it down very much
that's not narrowing it down
guy who did the [ __ ] holy roman
empire
the guy not pippin um
pep in the short that was much later
hold on people where's my glasses i got
them getting serious now
oh you dropped your glasses earlier what
you doing
you're gonna come up and show your butt
to the camera come on seeing if
anybody's [ __ ]
oh she's nobody knows she thought about
it she thought about it
she thought about jumping up and putting
her butt in the camera but she didn't
yeah can we um
can we please talk about the holy
foreskin okay go ahead
this is my favorite i don't know why but
this is my favorite
delicious relic i love
that i i love the um
i guess the the game
of the you know people that were in on
this [ __ ] religious relic
uh you know gimmick back in the day
and they're sitting there like they're
reading through the bible it's like okay
like
what what can we like sell as a relic
okay so
we can't do like toes or fingers or
nothing like that because jesus was
supposed to be ascended to heaven so
what's left
like what what kind of bodily [ __ ]
because that's gonna be better
than stuff that just like touched his
body like the shroud of turret or like
the crown of thorns or whatever
so we need something that's like part of
his body that's going to be like way
better
so we can sell that for a lot more so
it's like dude he was jewish right
yeah that which means that he got
circumcised whereas that was like
where's that we're skinner oh my god
that's it you're a genius
so i kind of feel like that was like the
the [ __ ]
mindset behind that [ __ ] so in that way
i'm kind of like i respect that
yeah but so i feel like
so as i said there's like the holy
foreskin or prepuce as it was called
there were at one time about
as far as i know about 13 of these like
circulating around europe
well there's a lot of kids getting
circumcised they're like let me get that
circle that's what they need
for skin save that yeah which is like
it's hilarious but that must have been
what happened yeah it's like we have to
save that so like later
on we can like sell it to some churches
like this is because it's like it's not
like they can check
right you can't do a dna test that's
what i mean they can't check
imagine just a little bitty tiny piece
of skin right off a little [ __ ]
newborn
[ __ ] surviving for [ __ ] 1500 years
1600 years
i ain't buying that [ __ ] the thing that
they do they put that [ __ ] they must
have pickled that [ __ ]
so the thing that cracks me up about
this and like look
like middle in the middle ages like even
some [ __ ]
like you know revered like
you know middle ages like painters and
stuff like that
did paintings of jesus getting
circumcised like here's the baby and it
was like the my favorite one i can't
remember like who painted it
was it ten toreno i can't even remember
but whoever painted it
like the face on the baby is the best
he's just kind of like looking like are
you really [ __ ] doing this right now
because they're like
flipping it up with like [ __ ] hedge
clippers or whatever
and he's just like what do you do it's
like seriously bro
and like the look on his face is just
like hilarious to me
but like so the fact that they that they
did that
and then like all these
churches paid money for this it's like i
can understand why the church has paid
money because the churches probably knew
that it was [ __ ] they were just like
yeah but we're just gonna buy this for
people to come look at
because that was what you did so i'm
more like fascinated by the people
that came and like looked at the [ __ ]
and like
revered the [ __ ] like oh yeah look it's
like this little strip of skin
and it was like the foreskin of jesus
[ __ ] would have been about the size of a
damn thumb yeah it's like a little
tiny like it was a baby it was a baby
foreskin that's like this big
yeah like how impressive could that be
so it's like the fact that like
pilgrims would come from like all over
the [ __ ] region
and like look at this [ __ ] and they
probably had like some big ship built
like they had like a [ __ ]
they had a pillow on it they had like
all kind of gold-plated [ __ ] around it
or everything and like all these people
like stroll through like
oh and then they like drop money in the
[ __ ] that is like [ __ ] hilarious yeah
here's something else
i can point out is that
all these little christian places those
little places where you went on
pilgrimages and [ __ ]
it was kind of like the medieval version
of the ancient version of disney
well yeah that was like they didn't have
disney world but they didn't have disney
world
anything fun today that's what it was
like yeah all right
they all kind of worked together and
they all built themselves in real
handy locations so you could walk from
one place to
another and there were a lot of them on
certain roads
that they headed towards the holy land
you know what i mean and it was all
these people making money on them
yeah it was like the whole route yeah
and it was evidently real commercial you
know
they had vendors around it hotels yeah
whole economy was like sprung up around
the [ __ ]
and they would just take any old thing
and rename it and give it a christian
title and then try to find somewhere
where they could kind of weasel that
into the
you know this is from the bible when
actually it was some kind of ancient
roman ruin it had nothing to do with the
bible
you know like they're be old cisterns
and [ __ ]
you know i mean they say oh this is the
pit where you know what i mean
um christians were thrown and this is
where
uh you know they they'd name some [ __ ]
you know
some saint this is where saint augustine
got thrown
into the [ __ ] pit you know what i
mean just they would make [ __ ] up
well that's what i mean they could say
anything and honestly they could just
rob a random grave and pull a finger
bone or a toe bone out and say it
belonged to any
like saint that you wanted to name and
they could put that in a little like
they
build a fancy [ __ ] [ __ ] around it and
it's like you could pay
you like people would pay to like go see
that [ __ ] yeah it was a really like i
said a whole economy looks
going up around this stuff now i don't
know
i'm pretty sure that those people knew
that it was that they were
they were gifted but i think i really do
believe that the church
believed that they were telling the
truth um i think
there were i think there were some guys
that knew it was [ __ ] but i think in
general
the average person in the church you
know a bishop or a cardinal or whatever
he believed what the bible said he
believed in christianity or i don't even
think they cared one way or the other
i think i think they believed it i did i
think that they knew that the stories
were [ __ ]
or partially [ __ ] but i think that
they believed jesus into jesus and in
jesus teachings they believed in heaven
and they believed in
god and all that i believe that they did
i don't
i don't see any evidence i don't there's
no evidence has survived
to even give a hint of the fact that
they thought that they were lying
about the [ __ ] about the meanings of
the [ __ ]
of the [ __ ] like i said i don't think
that they
that they saw it as lying in the same
way that we would perceive it nowadays
i think even i think they were just like
somebody sold them a finger bone
and said hey this is doubting thomas's
finger bone which is another like
religious relic that
uh you know that's very common in europe
i feel like somebody sold them that and
they were just like
fair enough i don't think they really
thought about
whether it was really that or not i just
kind of feel like well we can make money
off this
um and or it will bring people
into the faith so it doesn't matter if
it's really his finger bone or not
yeah that's not the same as what i don't
think they thought about it too much
i think that they knew that those were
what i would say
holy forgeries or holy you know it was
i think they considered that to just be
a means of getting people into the
church and
seeing their version of the truth yeah
that's what that was
but there's no evidence
to support the idea that they thought
christianity was a falsehood
no i don't think they did i don't think
they did they did not they thought it
was real
yeah they thought it was real and that's
why they were doing these forgeries is
they were trying to bring people to what
they thought was the truth
that's what i'm saying i don't think
they really thought
i think they were just like ambiguous
about like whether they thought it was
really that or not
i think they thought at some point it
didn't really make a difference
because if it brought people into the
fold
then it didn't matter if it was false
right if it was false
like because on a spiritual level level
it was real
yeah you know what i mean because it was
um you know fulfilling its purpose yeah
they were all trying to get them to
accept the blood of christ
right and that they were all trying to
get them to to
hold to to to join the church to believe
the church
so they could go to heaven they were
going to make money during that
but they believed that it was about
going to heaven i don't believe i don't
believe that
for like some people have said that oh
it was all false they didn't believe it
they're a bunch of atheists and they saw
all these christians as suckers
no no well i'm sure like some of them
did
very i think that that was like i think
it was a minority
i think and i think as you went up in
the ranks of the [ __ ] church
i think they got more pious actually
yeah i think the one the street level
guys probably knew that there was an
element of grift to it and probably
didn't believe it
but i think once you started getting up
into the [ __ ] very high levels of it
i think they actually believed
themselves to be god's representatives
on earth
yeah they weren't they probably did they
weren't [ __ ] and like i said they
could justify it yeah ken asked what are
your thoughts on the supposed blood in a
bottle or jar that is hundreds of years
old but turns liquid at certain times
i'm actually going to talk about that in
a minute
um because that's actually on my list so
like i said
um you know other than shroud of turin
there have been some other
similar kind of uh religious relics you
got the pseuderium of oviedo
which is i think i have a picture of
that actually let me scroll down
uh here it is which to me doesn't look
like [ __ ]
but i've seen some other like kind of
images of that where it kind of looks
like a face
this is supposedly um you know another
thing where
they're like that was something that
covered jesus's body so that's another
thing
um a blood stained cloth that looks like
it was wrapped around the head however
there's also the more famous like
veronica's or the veil of veronica which
was supposedly the thing that was
wrapped around his face
so they can't both be true um i don't
think either of them are
you also have a thing called the image
of odessa
which is also called the mandelion um
and there's two different images of this
and i think i have images of both of
them
this is one of them here right there
and this is the other one
both of them are kind of acknowledges
paintings but the thing
the reason why these are important is
because
these kind of um came about like pretty
early in a in a lot of early writings
where a lot of people who were kind of
like advocates of the
authenticity of the shroud of turin
are sometimes referring to writings
that might be referring to those two
images
which are paintings you know what i mean
so whenever somebody say is talking
about the shroud of turn and stuff
back in the day like you know back in
the middle ages or even back earlier
than that they might actually be talking
about these particular paintings that
were supposedly images of jesus like
painted while he was still alive even
though they probably weren't because
they're uh medieval looking
like i said there's also the veil of
veronica
which i thought i had yeah i have a
picture of that too
which look at that [ __ ] it makes jesus
look like such a dork
look at that [ __ ] yeah he's like
he looks like he i don't know i don't
know what that looks like
he just looks really dorky in that
picture but that's uh
supposedly you know when he was going to
you know he was carrying the cross and
he was going to the crucifixion and she
like comes and like wipes the sweat off
and it somehow
transferred his whole face onto there so
that's another kind of common
uh kind of [ __ ] there that is uh they
you also got your reliquary of the holy
crib
which supposedly has remnants of the
manger
of the baby jesus uh i think i have a
picture of that too because
look check this out this is like super
fancy the [ __ ] that they built to put
that channel look at that [ __ ]
that is fantastic so this supposed this
thing here
which kind of looks like you know you
want to cook a pot roast in it
but it actually has it supposedly has
remnants of the manger that baby jesus
was in
that is super fancy i love that [ __ ] i
tell you what
if if the stories of the baby genius
jesus are historical that baby would
have been nowhere near anything like
that
well no well no this this is just the
thing that they built to put the pieces
of the map
because i guess the pieces of the manger
yeah were just like pieces of wood
which you could get from anywhere i
wonder why i like that
but they had stories yeah so they had to
build this like fancy [ __ ] crock pot
looking thing to like put them in
jesus look a lot more impressive jesus's
manger
is just a reboot of noah's basket
that he was put in as a baby and sent
down the nile that's
that's all that is what are the chances
of finding the damn
basket that noah was put in and sent
down a dial
now i didn't check if there are any
religious like
relics of that but i would imagine there
might be yeah
although i feel like maybe not because i
fee the relic thing
that seems like a that's a mainly
catholic thing yeah
what's that like the whole relic
situation like the veneration of relics
well
yeah that's a catholic thing but um
i guess you could say yeah it's more
more a catholic thing yeah
that's i'm largely i'm trying to think
of anything in southern baptist that's
like that
and no not really velvet pictures of
elvis
velvet elvis is in your house is a
[ __ ] holy relic because
that's what i'm saying we all know that
elvis was god's
second son because he was from
mississippi that [ __ ] is sick
and he was handsome he was more handsome
than jesus
he could he could make it rain and stop
the rain with nearly a word
people don't understand the holy power
behind jesus they're behind
behind us i get them confused i get
confused
elvis elvis is elvis
is a mississippi demigod okay
yeah yeah that's mississippi's version
of jesus
y'all got your jesus and we got ours
i kind of i i kind of as handsome as
that [ __ ]
you that is that is like a greek god on
earth
yeah and he could sing yeah yeah
i get it yeah and and he could like you
know he could dance
he could dance in a sensual country he
married one of the most beautiful woman
on earth
so he must be the best of course that's
god's son
that's mississippi perseus
i got you i got you got it you
understand it now yeah yeah
even billy idol recognized even
billy idol recognized
didn't elvis die on the toilet eating
hamburger we're not gonna talk about
that
was he was he eating on the toilet
though he didn't die
that was all false
he staged his own death okay okay
and he lived for a long time and then
traps transcribed himself to heaven
i mean did you guys see bubba hotep just
like that
he killed the mummy that was trying to
like suck souls out of like old people's
[ __ ]
with jfk who was a black man with no
brain
but yeah so uh also there
are a lot of uh relics around the crown
of thorns because
i feel like [ __ ] around the crucifixion
like your crown of thorns type stuff
your nails
that seems like way easier to fake than
some of your like bodily relics because
all you have to do is like dig up some
like gross ass nail from somewhere
and then just say behold it is a nail
from the crucifixion
bringing all the money like you can
build like a whole [ __ ] reliquary for
that [ __ ] it's like and people will fall
for it which is like crazy to me
even probably nowadays i have seen
on ebay people are still
selling [ __ ] that is supposedly like
necklaces and [ __ ] like that that are
supposedly made with like pieces of the
true cross
genuine even back in the old days
even back in the [ __ ] 18th century
people were making
jokes about you could build a whole
[ __ ] building yeah
out of like the pieces of the true cross
that were like floating around out there
because this [ __ ] was
everywhere you could build the whole
everywhere the whole sequoia
redwood forest right
because like i said that's if you're
gonna do a religious relic
[ __ ] like that is like easier to fake
because you get to like like
knock a splinter off of anything and
just be like say it's
it's from the true cross it's like no
one's gonna even nowadays they can't
disprove that
yeah you can't disprove that carbon
dating
well yeah but nowadays you can but back
then you couldn't
back then they didn't care right i think
they didn't care i don't think they
cared i think they just liked the idea
yeah i mean i i those people were just
as worldly i think as we are today
what they were doing is that they were
going to tourist spots
along christian pilgrimages and they
were being sold little things off table
look i got a piece of the original cross
and you bought it
you bought it as kind of like a votive
offering type of
yeah yeah it was to prove your faith
more than anything else and it was like
it was like kind of like buying a
souvenir
like you've been on a pilgrimage yeah
and you buy it was like buying a
postcard
sure i'm pretty sure they sold that with
a wink
they were yeah you know what i mean i
don't think they took it seriously
it's kind of like we're living in it
we're living in a world that was very
religious there was a whole [ __ ]
there was a whole industry behind it
this was the
medium of the day they liked this kind
of [ __ ]
it didn't have to be real uh it was
i think they enjoyed a fakeness to it
actually
um they i think it was considered to be
like high-tech and sensational
and uh it was i think it was more about
proving your allegiance to your religion
and
virtue signaling that's a good way to
put it it's virtue signaling
yeah because you went there you brought
it there you bought it you got it
everybody sees that you have it you did
it it's very
signaling it's kind of like going to a
concert and buying a shirt
yeah or you know maybe more um
jermaine is going to st augustine and
buying
a you know like a screw or something
like from a pirate ship
you know what i mean you know it's not
from a pirate ship right but it's like
you're showing off you yeah you like buy
into like the fantasy exactly
it's only a couple of dollars it's like
it's not that big and you can show it
look i haven't said it like isn't that
fun
that's what i think they're doing that's
what i think i kind of feel like
well i don't know like maybe back in the
day they did kind of believe it but i do
kind of feel like the other half of them
was just kind of like ah
it's just kind of fun we just took a
trip and that was just kind of like okay
here's a souvenir here's a more modern
example
okay adolf hitler and the nazis did
everything they
could do to get hold of certain things
one of them being like the spear of
destiny
they knew that that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was more about virtue
signaling
it was about showing that they had all
these items
you know what i mean they knew that they
were it was
it's public relations it didn't happen
they knew that [ __ ] wasn't true but
that's what that's what
these pilgrims are doing like you said
it's just it's just virtue signaling
and it might be an idea too it's like
maybe it's real
but they don't really think it is but
it's like you like to think about that
maybe it is it's just like that [ __ ] you
kind of like when you buy a lottery
ticket and you're like this is the
winning one
or maybe maybe the people of our
generation is when you go on that home
shopping network and you're buying like
you know they were selling that kind of
[ __ ] off that too yeah the true
jesus cross from bethlehem yeah i saw
some water
from the [ __ ] you know from from the
[ __ ] dead sea
yeah i saw something about the dead sea
scrolls and they're going on they're
going to sell you some [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
vial of [ __ ] water from the dead sea
and a [ __ ] why didn't i get a scroll
and a scroll i'd be a millionaire with
the [ __ ] ten commandments on it
inside a glass [ __ ] jar
yeah and and then they're gonna sell you
some moses imagery
it's all about packaging packaging yeah
that's what they're doing
if you like pay for that packaging to
look good yeah people will pay for that
and then you take that back to your
village and [ __ ]
you know in florence or
your little village in [ __ ] you know
saxony somewhere
you go look i went to the holy lands
look what i got
yeah everybody's like jesus gave me this
it's like it's like boring people with
your slides of your vacation that you
took
yeah you know what i mean but yeah so
like i said that wasn't the only and
like i said there's a lot of weird like
bodily relics especially from saints not
so much from jesus because like i said
he was supposedly ascended so they only
have the foreskin
and the umbilical cord there's a lot of
that going around too like they they got
the foreskin and the umbilical cord
because that's
that's legit you can still have that
yeah but some of your saints like uh
saint catherine of siena
um her mummified head has made the
rounds um
obviously it's probably not her
mummified head something ken was talking
about earlier
was the blood of saint januarius now in
naples apparently two times a year
once in september and i think once in
may they have this little vial
of blood and they do a parade
and the blood is like powdered but then
twice a year
supposedly it liquefies now if it
doesn't liquefy
that year that means some bad [ __ ] is
gonna happen like some earthquakes or
some hurricanes or some [ __ ] like the
like natural disasters are gonna happen
um so they do like a parade every like
hoping it will liquefy
now supposedly it really does liquefy
but
i kind of feel like it's probably
not really they won't let anybody like
chemically analyze it
which is telling um they'll just let
people like shine the light through it
yeah and it looks like blood but you
could do the same kind of [ __ ] with like
i feel like um
the comedy is like it's iron oxide and
something else and if you did that like
it would normally be in a powder form
but like over a certain temperature it
would probably liquify
so i feel like that's probably what's
going on and i think that's
um a similar thing that's going on with
all these like crying statues like
statues that cry blood and all that kind
of other [ __ ]
i mean there's [ __ ] that they can do
where there's little like
pumps like going through them where you
can just
pump like i said like a reddish looking
fluid through that [ __ ] and like people
will come and see it like from all over
the world
but that's kind of what i feel like i
just feel like that's probably iron
oxide and some other [ __ ] that
liquifies at a certain temperature um
another relic is the
tongue of saint anthony of padua and
like i said doubting thomas st
thomas they also have his finger a bunch
of people have that
um also the body of saint mark
which supposedly is one of those ones
because i feel like that's
that's a thing where um people that are
sainted
their bodies supposedly don't decay
yeah so i feel like that's kind of like
they had that and they had saint cecilia
as well
where supposedly they died and like
their bodies didn't rot so then they
like put them on display and everybody
can like come look at them
but in a lot of cases and i don't know
if a lot of people know this but a lot
of cases
those the bodies that you're looking at
are replicas
right they're just yeah that's not like
the actual body they just like some
artists like made
yeah like a sculpture of it sculpture
yeah and like people are coming to look
at it going yeah
it's like it's it's a real body it's not
though now let me mention something
we're not picking on
christianity in particular
european religion was like this going
all the way back to the greek era
well yeah the greeks did this same thing
this is this is in european
culture to have
stories that come from holy scripture
or whatever is considered to be holy
scripture at the time
to make an industry around it and to
have
special effects to dazzle people
statues that move statues with [ __ ]
horses heads getting cutting off
they need cry blood blood yeah anything
that anything that reenacts
or so or proves some kind of a story out
of a [ __ ]
religious mythos what you doing pooh
she jumped up on the table okay hi
sweetie so
this isn't a christian phenomenon well
it's in this is a european phenomenon
it's an all over
and and it probably happens in other
countries in other
cultures too i mean i don't know the
chinese may have been doing [ __ ] like
this with their religions uh in the
japanese there's no talent
it all depends on what the story is
and what it is you have to believe in
order for this story to be true
like some buddhist stuff doesn't really
require this amount of faith because
there isn't
a god character in most forms of
buddhism some of them kind of have
things like gods and demigods but
it depends on how you read into it but
when you're dealing with european style
gods god's on mount
mount olympus fathers of the gods the
children of the gods
the demigods those are the children that
the gods are having with humans
whenever you have those kind of
religions usually there's going to be
some kind of stage show that goes along
with it because you've seen it
because like the more unbelievable the
stories that they're asking to believe
are
the more you need something to bolster
that
yeah and i think there was an element of
entertainment there seemed to be
evidently points to the fact that there
was a lot of money in this
and a lot of people watched these
[ __ ] things happening
i think it was the movie entertainment
slash nightclub of the time it was a big
social event
i don't necessarily think that people
believed
what they were seeing 100 percent i
think they wanted to believe it
or they were entertained by it i think
they were mostly just entertained by it
it's difficult to know what real people
thought
josephus said that people believed in
all kinds of crazy superstitions
mostly uneducated people uh that they
believed it to be true
that they went to [ __ ] temples and
saw these spectacles and enjoyed them
so i guess they kind of believed him or
wanted to believe him but it's difficult
to say well like i said i kind of feel
like
i'm not you know i'm not saying that the
people back then were
probably a lot more superstitious than
people now although maybe not as much as
we like to think
um but in a lot of ways i feel like they
were maybe just going to these things
like we would go to like a movie i think
that's what i think but they were kind
of
more more um inclined to believe in the
reality of it than maybe we are because
we know that that's not real
maybe they kind of in some ways knew
that it wasn't real but then like they
kind of wanted it to be real so they
just kind of like bought into it
they were definitely paying money they
were giving
voting uh votive offerings
and paying money to help prayers come
true
and they were wishing for things that
were very mundane a lot of times they
were in certain religions they would
write
the request down on a clay pot and pay
for a certain amount of money they'd
throw a clay pot into something
and you see that what they were asking
for it was real mundane
it was all just like their regular [ __ ]
it's like just the kind of [ __ ] that
most people know
yeah there's stuff like i want him to
love me or i hope i get married and
it was you know what i mean i need more
money in business and i hope this
business deal goes through
it was just normal everyday [ __ ]
so they were at least hoping that this
[ __ ] was true
they were just i feel like they were
probably just people nowadays like just
like
wishing yeah we're like just covering
all their bases yeah
it's like this is probably not gonna it
might not be
like but it's not going to hurt anything
growing up
growing up in brazil and having friends
that were both catholic
and believed in makumba i went to some
makumba
rituals which mukumba church is this is
is a [ __ ] trip
i actually like makumba church better
than christian church
it looks fun actually yeah you know you
go in and they're [ __ ] dancing and
they have the [ __ ] samba music going
and the girls are [ __ ] speaking in
tongues and
smoking on the cigars and blowing and
the makuma priest is there and [ __ ]
shaking hands and
you're giving him money and you got the
chickens and [ __ ] and they're killing
the chicken on the [ __ ]
thing and you know that this is about
buying a prayer you know what i mean
you know it's about and that you got
this guy's an intermediary
to the spirit world you know you know
what it is
and it's still basically what a priest
is
yeah i'm here in your church and i'm
going to pray and hopefully this should
work out because i'm here with you
yeah you're represented in god like i
said you're covering your base
right it doesn't hurt anything makumba
church
in brazil was like more so because it's
like the people's
church yeah you know what i'm talking
about and he was more in the underground
it was like some [ __ ] out of james bond
man i was a kid man [ __ ] listening to
the damn
you know [ __ ] duran duran one minute
and next thing you know i'm hungry like
a wolf one minute next minute i'm in the
makuba church
it was a trip you know i liked it um
the eighties were weird yeah
it was uh
i knew mokuma was [ __ ] but i wanted
to believe it and
it seemed fun at the time and maybe it
would help
yeah everybody around me says this [ __ ]
will help
you know what i mean well like i said i
kind of feel like even people nowadays
that
say they you know they get to a
crossroads in their life they're not
really sure what to do
and it's like you know they'll pay 20 30
bucks they'll go to a psychic
just like they don't necessarily believe
that what the psychic says is going to
come true
but they're just willing to pay 20 or 30
dollars because it will make them feel
better or
maybe make them feel more confident
about their own decision
or i mean people just need validation
you just need validation you want
somebody else to tell you
you know you're all right everything's
going to be all right
um you know you made the right choice
you did this so i think people really
need that and they're willing to like
pay some money to get that
yeah you know what i'm saying so i feel
like there was kind of a lot of that
going on too even though
back then they probably believed it a
little more than people now
but i don't think there was as much
difference as we like to think there was
you know what i mean because people are
still fairly superstitious nowadays
we're not all that different from people
back then
um but i do feel like i mean people
everywhere just like to be told
that their feelings are valid and that
everything's gonna be okay they just
want somebody else to tell
like an outside source to tell them that
and i feel like that was something that
you know nowadays people can get therapy
or you can talk to other people on the
internet but back then they didn't have
that
yeah so it's like the only place you
could get that was from religion
kanavasalan said he's he's got to take
his old man nap i understand i'm old man
too
he's got to take his old man nap his
religious experience is god
getting to him
we're joining the church church of
pugster so he's talking about we should
we should actually
we should actually make a church around
her yeah where did she go actually
khan's real name is jair hey jayers in
in uh
tijuana mexico jair do they have
things like macomb i know they have a
thing like makumba in in in in mexico
but what's it called in mexico
like the people's religion i know the
[ __ ] cartels have that santa muerte
[ __ ] but
like about that yeah but like
we could do a show about that but we'd
brazilian saints well yeah it's like a
catholic saints and asians
crossovers yeah it's a it makes a lot of
sense it's
it's extra canonical saints
in a catholic format yeah but without
without um um uh i guess you say a real
priest they're like street priests
now when i showed up a friend of mine
who was a cab driver took me
because he had to go all right he took
me and i wanted to see it
and the priest there looked at me kind
of skeptically but i paid my offerings
on the way in
there was only like 20 people in there
it was it was in his house
or in the backyard of his house i guess
he thought i was going to heckle it or
something but no i had a good time he
was happy that i was there
i was i was understanding it yeah it's
more about
vibing and it's
it's a folk religion i i enjoyed it it
was good
which like i said when you think of it
it's not it's not weird it's not no
i never thought of it no it wasn't weird
at all although in the 80s it would have
been something out of like a british
horror movie
well yeah you know what i'm talking
about that's how it would have been like
wow wow you know whoa
they killed a chicken well [ __ ] you
killed chicken before you eat it that's
what he was doing with it
which yeah i'm not into sacrificing
animals but
we eat chickens they yes well you had to
bring a chicken to start
they had to bring a chicken to start the
[ __ ] thing and certain people brought
chickens as offerings
and he killed the chickens but you kill
a chicken at the farm
before you eat it he didn't kill it in
any inhumane way
right cut his head off yeah and then
stuck it on which is the same thing
same thing you do cut his head off with
a hatchet and stuck it on a spike
yeah but then he you know and it stayed
there for the whole thing
but then he eats those yeah where that
comes from
back in the past it goes all the way
back to the old testament of giving
offerings
of the [ __ ] lambs and rams and
[ __ ] [ __ ] to the [ __ ] priests they
were eating all that stuff
yeah yeah well like i said not to eat
like the whole sacrifice saying it's not
all that weird because it just seems
like an extension of
it's just food right they're gonna eat
it anyway so it's like we're gonna give
a piece of it to the gods we're just
giving him we're cutting him off of
right slice right that's kind of like
where that comes from so it's not really
all that odd
it's just country food right seen in
that context it's not really that weird
no you just give you're just feeding the
priest
yeah that's what you're doing like i
said that's a lot less weird to me than
you know as we were talking about the
show like venerating a finger bone
which may or may not and probably not
have belonged to somebody that
you think you know who it is like some
saint or something when it could it was
probably just any random dudes it was
just like they just probably dug it out
of a grave somewhere
let me dug it out of a grave somewhere
it's like hey this is saint so-and-so's
finger bone give me all this money for
it so that seems like a lot more weird
to me
khan says that in mexico they got have a
lot of brujos which
in brazil is called bruja it means a
writ witch a witch witches
yeah witches
nothing wrong with witches witches are
pretty cool actually okay
so how's the show is it time to end the
show uh three hours and 34.
it's time to end the damn show my
goodness i think we've talked about it
enough we got
we did good actually it's funny because
i think dj maniac came in about the
two hour point or the two hour uh two
and a half hour point and he's like
hey i just got here how drunk are you
two
so we're still doing good though we're
still doing good shot of touring it's a
fake
it's a it's an interesting fake though
it's a good fake like i said i'm more
interested in how it was done
i'm fascinated by how it was i don't
really think it was like because i don't
even think jesus was a real person so
that's like not even an issue
but i'm interested in because like i
said i'm interested in art forgeries and
how that kind of [ __ ] was done so i'm
interested in it from a cultural
standpoint like a cultural context i'm
interested in it from that point of view
but i don't really think of it as a
religious relic i just think of it as
like an art piece
i'm the same way it's some kind of a
[ __ ] religious art
piece done by people who were well
purchased by people who were pious
yeah people who did it may have not have
been and like i said even
even [ __ ] that supposedly was a real
relic like the veil of veronica
they even know that certain popes
commissioned
copies of those like to kind of go on
tour
like put them in different churches so
they knowingly made
fakes of things yeah you needed special
effects for the favorites and that's
exactly why
that's how they justified it they
basically said well we need like an
image or something like to show people
so that they can understand right and so
they will come to the faith so they
didn't think of it as like
fooling anybody they just thought of it
as like a visual aid like i said
it's like a representation it would be
just
like today
making a movie like temptation of christ
yes it's not a [ __ ]
hoax or a fraud yeah no one's trying to
like
defraud it they're trying to just show
you the damn story and that's what
they're doing with this so
i i they were respectful to to the faith
i believe
and whoever made it obviously did a lot
of research
into because he got the thing with the
wrists right he got like
all the wounds right he got all that
kind of [ __ ] right
there's some [ __ ] he got wrong like the
proportions and the way the blood was
and stuff
but he actually whoever did it he or she
i don't know who did it but
whoever did it obviously did a lot of
research and put a lot of thought into
it
and as far as christ's myth
theory goes if there was a historical
jesus
nothing of him remains not it's not in
the scriptures
what was what's there now
is the official jesus is and it's
very much borrowed from a bunch of other
traditions jesus tm
and knowing how literature
and religious literature is formed and
we can get into that later when we talk
about
mormonism because mormonism and actually
scientology are great examples of how
religions are built
and once yeah those are kind of
fascinating because those are religions
that
you know formed in our lifetime right or
a little bit before our lifetime so we
can kind of see how it's developing like
in real time
and once you understand how religions
are built
you start to you start to think that the
chances of there being
a historical man named jesus jesus of
nazareth the one they're talking about
in those stories
nah yeah it's like even if that was even
if there was a real guy
named that at that time period that's
not the decision
that's not who's in the bible yeah and
that's that's like a
whole like synchronization of like a
whole bunch of different
it would be fictional and maybe real
people a good modern equivalent would be
like
well of course there's a superman he was
based on a young jewish boy living in
new york
yeah he wrote it they're like well
that's not superman superman could
[ __ ] fly he came from [ __ ] krypton
you know he did all kinds of other [ __ ]
that's not superman that's a jewish kid
living in new york right
that's the difference yeah all right the
the the
uh because of religious traditions and
you in rome
99.99 nine
there was no historical jesus this is a
mythological
creation
in a story it very much
you're basically you hemorizing an
archangel like
gabriel that's what you're doing yeah
that's what they're talking and that's
what i believe the original christianity
was
it was an angel above gabriel that sat
at the right hand of god
and the other angels his brothers killed
him
and the blood could wash away a man's
sin
and it happened on passover just like a
scapegoat ritual from jewish blood magic
yeah and if you accept the sacrifice no
matter where you
are who you are your sins will be washed
free
and you will not have to stand judgment
based upon mosaic
law that no one could pass those
standards so you're being saved by grace
not by the law yeah because jesus is
basically saying
yeah you're right yeah and it wasn't
and the religion was not made for your
average roman when it first started
it was made for jews living in rome
it was a way of jews that had lived in
rome for generations to kind of get out
of judaism and be in a more
roman style version of judaism that's
what it
that's what they're doing yeah would be
like imagine if you had
muslims in the united states for 150
years
they're americanized in every way except
for that religion they say you know what
let's change this religion a little bit
around change it around a little bit
to make it more american well the more
fit with the life the more fit with the
lifestyle
that's what they're doing but that's
what people do
they adapt yeah to the situation that's
what that's what happened
and i kind of feel like that's kind of
yeah sorry it's like everybody's talking
about
whatever word that is they're saying in
young frankenstein when the horse
winnie's
frau blue car that's when that's what
they say that's that woman's name
i don't know if it means glue or not but
that would be funny
if it was now [ __ ] man now i want to
watch young frankenstein
again then alex said you can't go around
getting [ __ ] by horses some things are
self-evident
you would think somebody's asking why
i've seen some porn like that though
somebody's asking why a jew is named
jesus in
well that wasn't his name originally
that's just like the translation of it
is it not
uh no there was a um
during that period there was a bunch of
extra canonical
[ __ ] i guess a good way to fan
fiction that's a good way to book yeah
there was jewish fan fiction about
the sons of god it gave
all the [ __ ] names of all those 72
angels
all right the top one was called jesus
evidently so it was the angel jesus
he was above gabriel that's why he's
called that and it's funny because in
certain parts of the new testament it
says the angel of jesus
it says it several times the angel of
jesus
yeah after he was just one of those yeah
after he had died he was called the
angel of the angel of jesus appeared
so that's giving it away right there
okay
jesus was an angel originally yeah yeah
above gabriel the son of god
because they were all sons of gods he
was the head son of god that sat at the
at the at the right hand of god he was
like the assistant manager
yeah he was above gabriel his name is
jesus
yeah all right well
let me go ahead and shut this off i
guess so holy crap we've been going
for last four hours i had no idea that
it was gonna go on this long i didn't
know there was so much
well i figured cause you know we're all
into the jesus mythicism thing so i
figured you would go off on that
um yeah so i guess we've been going on
for three hours and 45 minutes we're a
little bit [ __ ] up not
too [ __ ] up i've been way more [ __ ]
up than this on the show
but um yeah so we're gonna bid you all
good night
yeah remember like share subscribe on
all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show please go to our patreon
patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast uh if you go to our
patreon
and give as little as one or two dollars
a month you can actually vote
on what the next topic's going to be
what the next movie wrestling pact was
going to be
it's super fun so go over there and do
that if you haven't already
or if you'd like to give a one-time
donation you go to our blog
13 o'clock podcast repress there's a
link in the sidebar to a paypal account
which goes right to yours truly
and will help support the show if you
would like to do that
uh thank you very much ken you are very
awesome
with all your yeah thanks ken yeah we
sent us several today we're totally
gonna make it like some waffle fries too
yeah like with the thing that you
absolutely said yeah
and thank you for sending me that like
[ __ ] weird ass
article about the dude that pretended he
was a ghost because i'm still thinking
yeah
many hours later i'm just like damn yeah
it's just like that
it really rendered me speechless there
for a moment which really doesn't happen
that often so thank you for that
but yeah so uh we will see you guys
we'll probably do another live stream
tomorrow
uh we've watched a couple new movies on
netflix we're probably gonna watch the
or review those over the next couple
days so we'll
see you guys tomorrow uh thank you all
for stopping by thanks for your
donations
and everything like that so we'll see
you guys tomorrow bye